OUR APRIL SIXTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NATURAL RESOURCES
HEARING.
.
WE WILL BE STARTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND.
.
THERE IS THE SWEARING IN OF.
OUR NEWEST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SYDNEY CON LONGER.
A TAKING PLACE AT THREE O'CLOCK
IN SO.
SO WE MAY BE SHORT A FEW MEMBERS
PETA.
WE WILL START OF SUBCOMMITTEE.
I JUST FEEL ANNOUNCEMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
HAS BEEN APPOINTED FOR TODAY TO
FILL.
THE VACANCY ON THE COMMITTEE.
AND THE FOLLOWING BILLS HAVE
BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
HEARING.
ITEM NUMBER NINE A. B..
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE BY
MISTER PATTERSON.
ITEM TWELVE I ITEM ELEVEN BY.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY ONE.
BY MISTER LOWE.
AND.
ITEM TWELVE A. B. THIRTY THIRTY
BY MS CABALLERO.
SO.
THAT MEANS.
SHORTER MEETING TODAY VERY LONG
MEETING NEXT MONDAY.
THIS HEARING IS BEING TELEVISED
ON CHANNEL TWENTY TWO CAL
CHANNEL. AND A WE HAVE THIRTEEN
BILLS TO HEAR BY TWELVE AUTHORS.
FIRST.
ON THE SIGN UP IS A BIZARRE
WHEN PLEASE.
THE PLACE AND THAT WHEN YOU'RE
READY THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
FOR FARMERS AND.
WELL SMALLER OPERATIONS THAT
WOULD NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT FIFTEEN PERCENT OF THE
ANNUAL BUDGETS OF THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY. AND
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM. ALTERNATIVE
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AND
HEALTHY SOUL SOILS PROGRAM BE
USED TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. THIS WILL NUMBER
IMPROVE FARMER PARTICIPATION
PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
IMPACT OF CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS WITH ME
TODAY IS BRIAN SHELBY FROM CAL
CAN'T TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND
BRIAN SHOWED.
TWO MINUTES PLEASE SHARE AND THE
ASSOCIATE POLICY DIRECTOR OF THE
COMPANY CLIMATE NEGER CULTURE
NETWORK OR KHALKHIN.
WERE A COALITION OF SUSTAINED
LIKE ORGANIZATIONS FARMERS
RANCHERS CONSERVATIONISTS AND
SCIENTISTS.
WORKING TO UNLEASH THE POWERFUL
KIND SOLUTIONS ARE STATES FARMS
RANCHES HAD TO OFFER.
OF THE KIND OF SMART I PROGRAMS
YOU JUST HEARD REFERRED TO
HEALTHY CELLS PROGRAM SWEEP. AND
AMP ARE ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF
POLICIES WORLDWIDE.
TO HELP FARMERS AND RANCHERS
SLOWDOWN CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHILE PROVIDING MULTIPLE
BENEFITS TO THEIR BUSINESSES
LANDING COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER.
FARMERS AND RANCHERS HAVE TOLD
US LOUD AND CLEAR BASED ON THEIR
EXPERIENCE FOR THE FIRST ROUNDS
OF IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM'S.
THAT THE LACK OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE FOR THEM
HAS LIMITED THEIR PARTICIPATION.
AND IN SOME CASES PREVENTED THEM
IN THE STATE FOR MAXIMIZING
IMPACTS OF THEIR PROJECTS IN
TERMS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS.
WATER AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
THE ASSOCIATED FINANCIAL
SAVINGS.
BY INTEGRATING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE INTO THE PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING OUTREACH AND
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
SINCE WITH PROJECT DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL IMPROVE YOUR
SEPARATISTS SHOULD.
PARTICIPATION.
BREAK DOWN THE SILOS BETWEEN
THESE THREE PROGRAMS AND
MAXIMIZE THEIR OVERALL IMPACT.
I'MJOINED TODAY BY DAVE
PRINCETON HE'S THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE CAN YOU LOTS OF
FAMILY FARMERS AND LIKE THE OF
MY REMAINING TIME TO HIM THANK
YOU.
YES SO AND CALF WE WORK VERY
HARD AND TO HELP.
FARMERS APPLY.
TO THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM.
WE SPENT ON AVERAGE EIGHT HOURS
PERFORMER THAT WE WERE HELPING
FOR THEM TO APPLY IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE SMALLER
FARMERS AND PARTICULARLY THE
MINORITY FARMERS.
IT WAS ONE SPANISH SPEAKING
FARMER WHO CAME TO ONE OF OUR
WORKSHOPS AND HE SAID HE WAS
TRYING TO HELP OTHER SPANISH
SPEAKING FARMERS. BUT HE
COULDN'T FIND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THEM IN SPANISH.
AND SO THAT WAS REALLY ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE WANTED TO PUT
FORTH THIS BILL. TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THOSE RESOURCES WERE AVAILABLE
FOR MINORITY FARMERS ROUTE
DAHLQUIST THIS SMALL FARM
ADVISER IN FRESNO HELPED A LOT
OF MONTH FARMERS WITH THIS WEEK
PROGRAM. SHE FOUND IT WAS IT
EXTREMELY TAXING.
OF THAT THAT SHE HAD TO HELP
THEM IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM IN
ADDITION TO APPLYING FOR IT
REPORT TO THE GOVERNMENT AND SO
ON AND SO FORTH SO. I KIND OF
FEEL THAT THIS PROPOSAL HERE
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF THE FUNDS FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT FOR OF THAT FOR
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGE FARMERS.
WOULD IS IS A GOOD PLACE TO
START AND.
I REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
WE ARE.
LIKE TO WELCOME ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES SO JUST STATE YOUR
NAME.
.
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL.
GM ALSO WITH A CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE IN AGRICULTURE NETWORK.
ALSO REPRESENTING WINE
INSTITUTE IN THE OXNARD
PSYCHOLOGIES CENTER IN SUPPORT.
PAUL MASON PACIFIC FORCE TRUST
THIS IS SIMPLY MAKING THESE
PROGRAMS ACCESSIBLE TO THOSE WHO
NEED THEM THE MOST THANK YOU.
HE SAID I ONCE HAD A SPOTTER
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT THINKING.
JUST ALONG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMPASS COALITION BELIEVE THIS
WILL REALLY HELP WITH A HEALTHY
SOILS THANK YOU.
JENNIFER BANG ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY IN
SUPPORT.
JAMIE GOT HAVE CARBON CYCLE IT'S
YOU AND SUPPORT.
THE CLUB IS CONFERENCE HINTS
WASTE AND SUPPORT ONE I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORK ON THIS.
MELISSA ORDER ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY ONE MAKERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
POLL TO OURS WITNESSES THAT
ACTION NETWORK AND THE
CALIFORNIA FORMER JUSTICE
COLLABORATIVE.
WHERE NEITHER IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT WE JUST WANTED TO SHARE
SOME CONCERNS I WE'VE
APPRECIATED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE I AND ON
BEHALF OF THE FORMER COLOR
GROUPS THAT WE WORK WITH? A WERE
PUSHING FOR A LARGER PROPORTION
OF THE FUNDING TO GO TO SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS GIVEN THE
BARRIERS THAT MISTER BRONSON
DESCRIBES.
UP LINGUISTIC ARE BARRIERS AYE
AS WELL AS OTHER HISTORIC ON
BARRIERS I'LL WRITE BACK LATER
IF I LARGER PROPORTIONS THANKS.
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SLOWLY MAKE.
NO OPPOSITION
OKAY.
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
CENA.
MS WON'T TAKE A CHAIR I THINK
YOU AS A MEMBER IRWIN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT'S AT A
BILL THAT I THINK IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT OUR DISTRICT WANTS I
KNOW THAT I'VE TALKED TO SEVERAL
FOLKS. WHO WORK WITH HEALTH
HEALTHY SOILS GRANTS AND IS ONE
TO COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND IF YOU'RE TAKING A
CO AUTHORS I'D LOVE TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR A CO AUTHOR YES?
WE HAVE YOU ON.
WE DO NOT TO.
RIGHT.
OKAY SO.
WE ARE. WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW.
COULD GO THROUGH.
CHECK FIRST LET'S.
ESTABLISHED QUORUM AND THAT
SECTOR PLEASE CALDERON.
MEMBERS WHERE THIRTY THERE WERE
A TO G. HERE ACOSTA HERE.
ACOSTA HERE BLOOM. BLOOM
FAIRCHILD.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE FLORA.
FLORA HERE LIMON.
LIMON HERE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ HERE STONE.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A.
HEARD THE PRESENTATION.
WE HEARD FROM WITNESSES ON BOTH
SIDES ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
MISS IRWIN.
THE.
CANNELLA ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
ACT OF NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAM.
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE BY MUSLIM ON
AND SECOND BY MS AG MANNED.
CHARLES RECOMMENDATION IS I.
BROKE UP PLEASE.
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY MEMBER IRWIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ
LENDERS AYE STONE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEXT.
IN EVERY THIS RATING.
COOLEY MISTER COOLEY.
THIS IS.
I REMEMBER THIRTEEN AB THIRTY
THIRTY SIX.
BURGER MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
OF.
I AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
THIRTY THIRTY SIX RELATING TO
THE DEFINITION FAR FROM THE
DEFINITION OF SOLID WASTE.
I WANT TO THANK OF STAFF MEMBER
LIZ WITH NICK. MILAM WHO
ASSISTED ME ON THIS BILL. ARE
ALSO STAKEHOLDERS AND I JUST SO
WE HAVE AMENDMENTS HAD BEEN
TAKEN A LOOK TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ALL IT SHOULD PARTY'S
IS. TO MOVE THE BILL ALONG.
.
FOOD PROCESSING BY PRODUCTS ARE
CURRENTLY PASSED FROM HIS WAIST
AND A CALIFORNIA LAW.
SUCH A CLASSIFICATION CAN
TRIGGER BOTH LICENSURE IN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS UNDER
LOCAL FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS.
FOR INDIVIDUALS TRANSPORTED
THESE PRODUCTS PRODUCTS.
OF SUCH REQUIREMENTS CAN PUT
SIGNIFICANT BURDENS UPON
AGRICULTURE AND.
PRODUCERS
WHO OTHERWISE WOULD COULD
COLLECTED UC'S PRODUCTS AND PETE
FOR THEIR ANIMALS.
DIVERTING THESE MATERIALS FROM
THE LANDFILLS.
AB THIRTIES THIRTY SIX RELEASE
RECLASSIFIED BYPRODUCTS FROM
AGRICULTURE AND FOOD PROCESSING
THAT ARE USED IN LIVESTOCK FEED.
SO DOES NOT CONCERN WASTE
PRESERVE THEIR BUILDING OF
LIVESTOCK AND POULTRY PRODUCERS
TO USE AND TRANSPORT. SUCH PRY
PRODUCT FOR THEIR FEED.
I HAVE TODAY WITH ME.
AND NOEL CREAMERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRM PROTEST BY.
CAN BE.
MUCH DID MADE A SECOND DAY THIS
IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT BUT NO
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME AS A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH. US ON THIS
BILL. AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
SCOPE FORTY ONE PERCENT OF THE.
THE DAIRY COWS IN CALIFORNIA
THEY'RE THEY'RE EATING THESE BY
PRODUCTS FROM FOOD PROCESSING
THAT IT'S MAKING UP FORTY ONE
PERCENT OTHER RATIONS SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE AREN'T
ANY IMPEDIMENTS.
TO USING THESE BY PRODUCTS OF.
AND THIS CLICK THIS WOULD
CLARIFY THAT IT'S NOT WASTE IN
SHOULD BE CONTINUED TO BE USED
AS AN OFFICE
THAT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST OLD FIELD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION. I WANNA ECHO THE
POINTS MADE BY MS CREAMERS.
IN ADDITION TO REPRESENTING
RANGERS HERE I'M ALSO A PRODUCER
MYSELF AND I I PERSONALLY FEED
BY PRODUCTS FROM A BIRD AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THESE FEEDS
ARE. EXTREMELY.
BENEFICIAL TO ENSURING.
BOUNCE NUTRITION ESPECIALLY IN
TIMES OF A PROLONGED DROUGHT SO.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRING THIS
BILL FORD ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
THAT YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OF FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE.
WILL BE SOME OKAY.
I DO WE HAVE ANY WINNERS ON THIS
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
IF YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS UP
BETTER THAN A TWEENER.
I'M I'M HERE ON BEHALF MY NAME
IS KELLY AFTER HER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT IN ABOUT TWENTY
FOUR HOURS WILL BE ABLE TO
FORMALLY WITHDRAW OPPOSITION TO
PREVIOUSLY HAD.
AND I JUST WANTED IT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE BOTH THE
SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR FOR BEING
VERY RECEPTIVE THE CONCERNS WERE
EXPRESSED THE APRIL NINTH
AMENDMENT.
GO A VERY LONG WAY TO RESOLVING
THOSE WAS ONE LITTLE. WORD WE'RE
STILL GONNA HECKLING OVER BUT
ALL IN ALL WE'RE VERY VERY
PLEASED IN SUPPORT OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR JUST MONTHS THE CUT
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION WE
ARE REMOVING OPPOSITION AND THE
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WE DID
RAISE THAT IS BECAUSE AS I'M
MANY OF YOU KNOW. THERE IS A
MANDATE ON ORGANIC RECYCLING AND
WE ARE 䥢CERNED
THOUGH MUCH OF THIS MATERIAL
HASN'T BEING CONSIDERED A SOLID
WASTE ISN'T NESS RECOUNTED IN
THE WASTE STREAM. THERE'S A VERY
SIGNIFICANT OBLIGATION ON
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA TO DIVERT
THIS WASTE AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE ON THE ACCOUNTING OF THIS
WASTE.
THAT WE KNOW WHAT WE COUNTING
THIS THIS IS A LARGE VOLUME OF
MATERIAL WE NOT SAYING IT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED SOLID WASTE BUT AS
WE ACCOUNT FOR THE WAY WE
HANDLING THIS ORGANIC MATERIAL.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS PROBABLY ACCOUNTED FOR SO
THAT'S OUR MAIN CONCERN WITH
THIS.
CHAIR MEMBERS HAVE MARK A PRAYER
ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES I
WANNA ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
KELLY ASTOR. LA I ALSO WANT TO
COMPLIMENT OF THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US AND WHILE WE
HAVEN'T COME TO AGREEMENT YET ON
LANGUAGE.
WE'RE HOPING TO DO SO AND I
JUST WANTED TO LET THE COMMITTEE
KNOW THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MANY OF WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
NONE.
MEMBERS QUESTION.
MS EGGMAN. BUT THINK YOU BUT
THINGS COOLEY FOR TAKING THIS ON
ITS ONE OF THIS ONE ONE OF MY
FAVORITE PARTS OF NATURAL
RESOURCES WILL WE REALLY SEE THE
INTERSECTION OF AGRICULTURE AND.
AND THAT AND NATURAL RESOURCES
AND HOW WE WORK TO MAINTAIN OUR
OUR VIBRANT ECONOMY A BAG BUT
ALSO CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS THAT
WE MOVE THE STATE FORWARD MOVE
THE STATE FORWARD EXACTLY SO I
AM.
HEARTENED TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
NINE TRUSTED YOU GONNA GET TO A
GOOD PLACE ON THIS. AND I'D LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL.
MOTIONS ALREADY BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED WHOEVER THIRD. MUSICAL
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU I'M I'M SCHOOLEY OF
FOR THE BILL I.
GONNA I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL PRIMARILY BECAUSE I
HEARD FROM SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION TODAY THAT YOU'RE
VERY VERY CLOSE A WORD OR TWO.
ON THAT SAYS VERY ENCOURAGING IT
SOUNDS LIKE OUT WHERE IT'S
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND I HAVE TO SOME OF THE
SENTIMENTS.
OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE ABOUT THE.
YOUR WAY STREAMS OF THE
VERSIONS OF THINGSTHAT WE NEED
TO DO SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CAN THANK.
YOU FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS
SEEN KNOWN.
SHORTLY DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BROKE UP PLEASE.
ITEM THIRTEEN MAYBE THIRTY
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT TO CHANGE AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA ON
ACOSTA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ LENDERS AYE STONE.
SEVEN ZERO.
BILL IS OUT FOR GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT NEXT UP IS MISTER
GRAYSON.
AND YOU HAVE A TWO BILLS UP.
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
AB IN NINETEEN OH FIVE WHICH.
I UNDERSTAND YOU WANT TO
PRESENT.
FOR HEARING PURPOSES ONLY AND
NOT FOR A VOTE IS THAT CORRECT
MR GRACE. THAT IS CORRECT. AND
YOU ALSO HAVE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN.
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY.
WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED
WITH WORSE.
I WILL PROCEED WITH A.
BILL NUMBER AB NINETEEN ZERO
FIVE ALRIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ALTHOUGH I'VE DECIDED TO NOT ASK
FOR A VOTE ON AB NINETEEN ZERO
FIVE AT THIS TIME.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ON THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL AND THE PROGRESS THAT WE
HAVE MADE TO DATE.
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM IS
THE RESULT OF EXTENSIVE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN
STAKEHOLDERS THAT YOU MIGHT NOT
NORMALLY SEE WORKING TOGETHER.
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS TRANSIT
BEHIND THIS BILL LIES A SIMPLE
PREMISE.
THAT G.. IMPACTS ARE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO THE CAT TO
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT AND
THAT MOBILE SOURCES ARE THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF THOSE
EMISSIONS.
TO THAT END WE ATTEMPTED TO
CRAFT LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
ALLOW TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
THAT WERE BOTH PART OF A
REGIONAL STRATEGY TO REDUCE
GHGS.
AND WERE DESIGNED TO REDUCE CAR
TRIPS ON A PROJECT LEVEL TO MOVE
FORWARD EXPEDITIOUSLY.
AB NINETEEN ZERO FIVE DOES NOT
INHIBIT THE SEQUEL PROCESS IN
ANY WAY.
PROJECTS THAT REQUIRE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT WILL
STILL BE REQUIRED TO MITIGATE
FOR IMPACTS
HAVE A ROBUST PUBLIC INPUT
PROCESS. THAT CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVES
WHAT AB NINETEEN ZERO FIVE DOES
IS REQUIRED PROJECTS ARE FIXED
NOT SIMPLY STOPPED WHEN A
PROBLEM IS FOUND WITH THE E. IR.
IT APPLIES THE ADJUNCTIVE RELIEF
PROVISIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAD PREVIOUSLY GRANTED TO
PROJECTS LIKE THE KINGS ARENA.
THE WARRIOR SERENA AND THE
CAPITOL BUILDING ITSELF
THE GREEN TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
STOPPING PROJECTS IS EXPENSIVE
ACCORDING THE CALTRANS INDEED GS
ESTIMATES?
A YEAR LONG DELAY CAN ADD UP TO
FOUR PERCENT TO THE COST OF THE
PROJECT
WHEN A PROJECT COST ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
WELL YOU CAN DO THE MATH.
IF YOU'LL REFER TO YOUR HANDOUT
THE LA JOH IDENTIFIED AT LEAST
TWO PROJECTS COSTING OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS THAT THIS BILL
WOULD APPLY TO THAT WERE STOPPED
DO THE SECRET LIT A SEQUEL
LITIGATION.
CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION AND A
LIGHT RAIL IN SAN DIEGO.
BOTH OF THESE PROJECTS WERE
DETERMINED TO REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED TAKING CARS OFF
THE ROAD BOTH OF THEM WERE
INCLUDED IN REGIONAL PLANS TO
REDUCE GHGS.
AND BOTH OF THEM WERE STOPPED
FOR OVER A YEAR BECAUSE THEY
WERE ULTIMATELY OWE IT BEFORE
THEY WERE ULTIMATELY ALLOWED TO
PROCEED.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELVES DO WE WANT
PROJECTS OF THIS MAGNITUDE. WITH
THESE LARGE SCALE BENEFITS TO
OUR ENVIRONMENT
CONTINUE TO BE SUBJECT TO
INJUNCTION BECAUSE OF A LAW
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
CAN WE REACH OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
IN AIR QUALITY GOALS THIS WAY.
AND AS WELL CAN WE TELL OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT WE ARE USING
THEIR TAX DOLLARS IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY ABOUT NINETEEN
AB NINETEEN ZERO FIVE. S. B. ONE
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT NEW FUNDING
FOR TRANSIT THE TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM
ALONE. WERE RECEIVED FIVE OR
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FROM S. B. ONE MONEY
THESE COMPETITIVE GRANTS FUND
PROJECTS THAT MODERNIZE TRANSIT
SYSTEMS INCREASE RIDERSHIP
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND IMPROVE SAFETY.
A MINIMUM OF TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF THIS FUNDING IS DEDICATED TO
PROVIDE DIRECT BENEFIT TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
IS IT FAIR TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT A POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THIS MONEY IS GOING
TO BE EATEN UP BY COST INFLATION
WHILE THE PROJECT LANGUAGE WAS
IN COURT.
I WANT TO THANK THE ADVOCATES
WITH PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE THAT ARE TRANSFORM
CLIMATE PLAN FOR THEIR EFFORTS
ON TAILORING THIS BILL SO THAT
IT ONLY APPLIES TO PROJECTS
WOULD TANGIBLE IMPORTANT
BENEFITS TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO STEP ACROSS
THE TRADITIONAL LINES OF WORK
TOWARDS AN INNOVATIVE SOLUTION
IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF
THINKING THAT WILL BE NECESSARY.
IF THIS STATE IS GOING TO ADAPT
AND THRIVE IN A CHANGING
CLIMATE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
NOT ASKING FOR A VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE AT THIS TIME.
BUT I DO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS UPCOMING
YEAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY MUCH AND.
YOU HAVE WHAT'S WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NO WITNESSES HELPING.
OR DOING I GUESS WE DO.
WILL TAKE A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GAP IN CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MANY MITCHELL FULL BORE HA AND
I'M AN ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH A CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. WE HAVE TO COMMEND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AND
STAFF FOR SPEARHEADING THIS
POLICY IDEA AND DEVELOPING THIS
CONVERSATION TO HELP STREAMLINE
SEQUEL ALSO PER SERVING. PROJECT
DELIVERY. WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT STRIKE A BALANCE IN
DELIVERING THE BENEFITS OF A
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT WHILE
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESSING. ITS
POTENTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
WITHOUT THE COSTS AND DELAYS
CHIU TO LITIGATION.
ARE WE RAIN REMAIN COMMITTED AND
HOPEFUL TO WORK WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND A STAFF AND IS
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I MATTHEW BAKER POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE WE DID NOT
TAKE A FORMAL POSITION ON THIS
BILL AS OF YET BUT. WE DID
PARTICIPATE A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STAFF
AND WE APPRECIATE THEIR EFFORTS
TO MAKE THIS.
A STRONGER BILL WE HAD CONCERNS
IN THE BEGINNING BUT WE NEED
SUPPORT THE INTENT OF TRYING TO
PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO. PROJECTS
THAT MEET STATE GOALS FOR FEE
IMPERIAL ACTION AND WE AND WE
THOUGHT THAT THE AS AMENDED WITH
HEAD IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE CONCEPT
SOME THANK YOU.
IN THE STATE OF ALL CHECK ON
BEHALF OF SUNBURN AND YOU KNOW
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AND BEEN TURNED COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT.
ADAM RIGHTLY WITH CAL CHAMBER
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
RIGHT AND WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FOR.
HOW JONES IS HERE CLUB
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVEN'T POSITION
ON THE BILL UP FOR A LOT OF
REASONS I THINK A LOT OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARD LAST WEEK
REGARDING INJUNCTIONS AND HOW
THEY CAN PROTECT THE PUBLIC OUT
WE JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR PUTTING A POSITIVE
EVERYTHING AND? HOPE THAT WE
HAVE FOR FULL DISCUSSIONS OF THE
INNER.
AFTERNOON TURNED MEMBERS DAN
POEM FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT YOU HEARD LAST
WEEK THE COUNCIL'S CONCERNS ARE
NOT FOCUSED ON SEQUEL OR THE
MAYOR TO THE PARTICULAR
PROJECTS.
THAT WOULD BE COVERED ARE
FOCUSES SOLELY ON THE COURT
IMPACTS OF LEGISLATION.
UP LIKE THIS SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
THERE HAVE BEEN. ABOUT THIRTY
BILLS INTRODUCED FOLLOWING
EITHER AB NINE HUNDRED OR SB TWO
NINETY TWO OF THOSE THIRTY BILLS
EIGHTEEN INCLUDING THIS BILL HAD
THE PROPOSED LIMITS ON
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
THE COUNCIL'S CONCERNS ARE THAT
THE COURT HAS BROUGHT EQUITABLE
POWERS
IN SECRET AND ANOTHER MATTERS TO
FASHION. THE APPROPRIATE LEAVE
BASED ON THE FACTS AND THE LAW
IN FRONT OF THE JUDGE IN THIS
PARTICULAR. CATEGORY OF OF.
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AM IT SAYS THAT
ONLY IF THE PROJECT WOULD RESULT
IN A THREAT OF IMMINENT HARM TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH. OR INTERFERE
WITH NATIVE AMERICAN ARTIFACTS
OF THE COURT WOULD BE PRECLUDED
FROM. FASHIONING AN INJUNCTION
BASED ON THE FACTS IN THAT
PARTICULAR CASE WHICH THEY OFTEN
DO IN THESE CASES THEY ISSUE
TARGETED INJUNCTIONS IT IS FOR
THOSE REASONS THE COUNCIL'S.
ALRIGHT ANY ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SEEING
NONE QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS LAMONT.
AS ONE IT THINK THE AUTHOR I
KNOW THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU TO
THE DISTRICT TO CALIFORNIA. AND
I THINK AND YOUR APPROACH TO
REALLY TRY TO UNDERSTAND IT
THINK.
WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM AS
MEMBERS BUT ALSO TO ENGAGE BOTH
THE OPPOSITION AND THE
SUPPORTERS A THINK?
IS VERY YOU KNOW NOTABLE.
AND IMPORTANT IN THIS AND SO.
I WISH YOU KNOW ALL OF US LUCK
IN TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF
THERE'S A PATHWAY TO HELP. YOU
KNOW OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM A
HOUSING SYSTEM SO MANY OTHER
AREAS.
AND DOING IT IN A WAY THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH ALSO PROTECTING
SOME OF THE LAWS THAT.
YOU KNOW SOME COMMUNITIES FIND
PARTICULARLY USEFUL IN AND
HELPING US KEEP THE ENVIRONMENT
AYE WHAT IT IS SO I THINK YOU
THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO.
.
CONCLUDE THIS SAID DISCUSSION
FOR TODAY.
BY JOINING THIS LIMB ON AND
THANKING YOU MISTER GRAYSON FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS EFFORT
TO. BRING THE NONTRADITIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO.
TRY TO OF FURTHER EXPLORE.
SEEK REFORM.
AS I'VE INDICATED.
IN THE PREVIOUS MEETING AND THE
IN THE PAST I M.. CERTAINLY OPEN
TO ANY AND ALL SEEK REFORM
IDEAS.
.
BUT MY. PRIMARY CONCERN WITH
WITH YOUR BILL WAS AS LAID OUT
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
YOU WHILE YOU HAVE ADDRESSED THE
GHG EMISSIONS OR ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS A GHG EMISSION
CONSIDERATIONS AS WELL AS THE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
THOSE ISSUES THERE ARE AS WE
DISCUSSED EIGHTEEN.
FACTORS ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS
THAT THAT THAT MAY BE CONSIDERED
UNDER SEQUEL. AND FOR ME A MOST
IMPORTANT WHERE THE TWO THAT
WERE HIGHLIGHTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POTENTIAL
IMPACTS ON OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES SUCH AS. POTENTIAL TOXICS
IMPACTS OR WATER QUALITY IMPACTS
INYO SO THOSE ARE JUST A TO.
OF OF MANY EXAMPLES OF.
THE REASON WHY.
SEQUEL.
REFORMERS BEEN SUCH A TOUGH NUT
TO CRACK AND THAT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT YOU SHE'S IN ABOUT VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED BUT.
.
HOW DO WE? BALANCE THE.
PROTECTIONS THAT SEEK WERE.
OFFERS WHO WITH THE DESIRE TO
ATTEMPT TO ELIMINATE THE ABUSES
OF SEQUEL AND I THINK THAT IS
THE REAL CHALLENGE THAT. YOU ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS AND THAT WE
APPRECIATE.
YOUR EFFORTS PACKAGER.
NEXT SO WE HAVE A ITEM FIFTEEN.
A. B.. THIRTY ONE SIXTY AND.
.
YES.
AND WE DO HAVE WITNESSES COMING.
AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE SIXTY
WHAT'S WILL EXEMPT THE SALE OR
LEASE OF SPECIFIC FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROPERTIES.
FROM THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION IS GIVEN
THE RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL A
ROLE THAT WAS CREATED THROUGH S.
B. FIFTY LAST YEAR.
FIRST.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND AYE AYE I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS PER THEIR
ANALYSIS.
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY
PROVIDES A VERY LIMITED
EXEMPTION FOR SPECIFIC FEDERAL
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND THE BASE REALIGNMENT CLOSER
ACHEI BRAK.
BOB TRANSFER IN REDEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM
MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO ONE OF
THESE FORMER BASES
THE CONCORD NAVAL WEAPONS
STATION.
THE CITY OF CONCORD IS THE LOCAL
REDUCE AUTHORITY FOR THIS FORMER
MAYBE BETTER A NAVAL BASE AND
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH THE US
NAVY FOR OVER THIRTEEN YEARS. ON
THE BASIS TRANSFERRED TO LOCAL
CONTROL AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WOULD EXEMPT THIS FEDERAL
PROPERTY FROM RECENTLY ENACTED
STATE LAW. WHICH WOULD ENABLE
THE CITY OF CONCORD TO COMPLETE
THE FEDERAL TRANSFER PROCESS AS
PART OF THE CITY'S REUSE
PROJECT.
FOR THESE REASONS I SPECIFICALLY
ASK FOR.
AND ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
I WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO MY
WITNESSES AND ALLOW THEM TO SELF
INTRODUCE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND FOLKS OF
THE UC COMMITTEE.
I'M EDDIE BURSTS AND I AM THE
MAYOR OF CONCORD AND.
IN FULL DISCLOSURE HE'S MY
MUTUAL CONSTITUENT.
THE CITY OF CONCORD AS BEEN SAID
IT'S BEEN WORKING FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS.
WITH THE NAVY AND THE BRACH
TO.
CHANGE THE CONCORD NAVAL WEAPONS
STATION FROM A EMPTY.
MUNGER DRIVEN LAND INTO A
REGIONAL PARK.
LOCAL PARKS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
JOBS AND EVEN A UNIVERSITY.
IN THE PROCESS NOT ONLY WE SPENT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF A
TREASURY.
BUT OFF RESIDENTS HAVE PUT IN
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND HOURS.
OF RESIDENT PARTICIPATION IN
THIS DECISION AND GETTING US TO
THIS POINT.
THE BRAKE SYSTEM AS IT FUNCTIONS
IN OUR CITY.
IS SOMETHING WHICH ALLOWS FOR
LOCAL CONTACT AND ALLOWS US TO
ADVANCE TO CHANGE WHAT IS
CLEARLY. A UNDESIRABLES
ACTUATION IN OUR LAND AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
SOMETHING THAT IS BOTH
PRODUCTIVE AND FALLS WITHIN THE
VALUES AND THE QUALITY OF
PRIORITIES THAT WE IN THIS
STATE.
HAVE BEEN PROUD TO HOLD.
IT WOULD BE UNFORTUNATE IF AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF A BILL DESIGNED TO PROTECT.
WOULD BE USED TO DELAY. THE
ACTUAL CREATION.
OF A VALUABLE ASSET TO THE
ENTIRE STATE.
EVERYONE IN CONTRA COSTA EAST
BAY WILL BENEFIT FROM OUR
PROJECT.
THE BRAC SYSTEM HAS WORKED WITH
US.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS WORKED WITH
THE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
US.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE AND THE
PROBLEMS THAT BROUGHT ABOUT.
SP FIFTY.
THEY DON'T EXIST IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE AND WOULD BE
A SERIOUS DISAPPOINTMENT TO MY
CONSTITUENTS. MY COMMUNITY AND I
BELIEVE THE VERY ESSENCE OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN US TO GET
THERE.
SO THANK YOU AND PLEASE OF GIVE
US AN AYE MOTION.
CHAIRMAN GUY PURE KEY THE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY REDUCE
PLANNING FOR THE CITY OF
CONCORD.
I'M HERE PRIMARILY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE UP BUT I DID WANT TO MAKE
ONE.
THE TICKET OR POINT THIS LIMITED
EXEMPTION THAT WE ARE SEEKING
FOR BRECHT PROJECTS BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ENABLES THE EXPANSION OF LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF MANY STATE POLICIES WITHOUT
UNDERMINING THE INTENT OF SP
FIFTY AND THAT'S WHY WE SEEK
THIS EXEMPTION. AND ASK YOUR
IBOOK.
ANY OTHER FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROVIDER USA
PROPERTIES FUNDS STEVEN CALL IN
SUPPORT.
A FURTHER WITNESSES
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE OF QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT.
.
MISTER GRAYSON I BELIEVE THIS IS
A GOOD BILL AND I'M RECOMMENDING
AN AYE VOTE.
WHICH ELECT CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MOVED AND SECONDED ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
MS LIMA.
SECONDED.
I AM FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
BY MEMBER GRAYSON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE ROUTE
SIXTY AYE ACOSTA.
I COSTS AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LIMON YE. MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
STONE.
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO BILLS OUT
THAT USER.
ALRIGHT NEXT WE HAVE A MISTER
BERMAN PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN A. B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE.
ALL.
FOR.
ALRIGHT WHAT A GENTLEMAN.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
I IS HERE TO PRESENT ITEM NUMBER
ONE. AB NINETEEN NO ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES L. A. B. NINETEEN NO
ONE WOULD EXTENDED EXISTING
SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR CITIES OF
LESS THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
RESIDENTS FOR THE REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE OF EXISTING ROADWAY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL I WILL ACCEPT THE TO
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE TWO
OF YOUR ANALYSIS. AND I THINK
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR YOUR
STAFF HAS BEEN GREAT TO WORK
WITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ABOUT THE NATURE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS EMINEM'S JOYFUL BORA I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION WHICH
SUPPORT AB NINETEEN A ONE.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT IT WITH
EXTEND AN EXISTING AUTHORITY TO
HAS BEEN IN STATUTE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE.
THE COMMISSION BELIEVES THAT
THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE
MONEY AND TIME WITH DELIVERING
MINOR.
CRITICAL REPAIRS TO
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER EIGHT
EXISTING SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
HOW WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMISSION IN MOVING THIS
RECOMMENDATION FORWARD AND
RESPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
CAPTION USAGE IN MEMBERS GUS
CORY GOING TO HAVE TO
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FOR
MONTEREY COUNTY JUST WANNA CHO
TO COMMENTS MADE BY.
THE CTC MORE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR ITS AUTHORSHIP OF THE
MEASURE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU A WITNESS IN SUPPORT
NASTASIA OF. BEHALF THE SENDER
NEED IN THE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION INTO IT IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON BEHALF
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT.
AT A RALLY ON BEHALF OF CAL
CHAMBER ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
THIS SURE OBERNOLTE.
YOU HAVE AGREED TO ACCEPT TO.
THE COMMITTEES A PROPOSED
AMENDMENT.
.
THERE WERE SOME QUESTIONS
RAISED.
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IN
TERMS OF.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH.
THE SIX THAT THIS EXEMPTION HAS
BEEN USED.
.
BUT.
I WILL BE VOTING AYE AND SOUP
SUPPORTER YOUR BILL.
BUT.
THIS TIME I WILL NOT BE MAKING A
RECOMMENDATION.
FOR THE REST THE COMMITTEE.
ON THIS BILL.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE ARE THIS IS
A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT EXTENDS
AN EXISTING EXEMPTION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
IF YOU VERY MUCH.
MOTIONS MADE AND SECONDED ROLL
CALL PLEASE ITEM ONE A. B.
NINETEEN NO ONE BY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE. THOUGH MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE REFER TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MIGHT SEARCHING Y. ROUTE TUCCI
AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE ACOSTA AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
LIMON.
LIMON NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
STONE.
SEVEN ZERO.
ELISSA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF YOU.
MISTER BERMAN.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES I
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY TO PRESENT
A. B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE A
BILL WHICH WOULD ADD THE
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES.
AS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD WHEN NATURAL RESOURCE
RELATED MATTERS ARE UP FOR
CONSIDERATION.
THE PUBLIC WORKS BOARD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING AN
IMPROVING THE LAND ACQUISITION
TRANSACTIONS FOR MOST STATE
DEPARTMENTS
INCLUDING LAND FOR STATE FIRE
STATIONS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
FACILITIES AND PUBLIC SAFETY
RADIO COMMUNICATION SITES. TO
NAME JUST A FEW RECENT PROJECTS.
AS PART OF ITS CHARGE THE BOARD
HERE'S AND DECIDES UPON
ACQUISITION OF REAL PROPERTY OR
CONSTRUCTION OF PROJECTS FOR
ENTITIES. UNDER THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THAT ARE
INTENDED TO IMPROVE NATURAL
RESOURCES MANAGEMENT PROTECT
LANDS OR PROVIDE RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES.
WHILE LAND ACQUISITIONS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
NATURAL RESOURCES HAVE COMMON
COMPONENTS.
THE PROGRAMMATIC GOALS OF
NATURAL RESOURCES PROJECTS MAY
BE UNIQUE FROM OTHER ISSUES
WITHIN THE BOARD'S JURISDICTION.
AND THE EXISTING MEMBERSHIP OF
THE BOARD.
WHICH IS THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
THE DIRECTOR OF CALTRANS IN THE
DIRECTOR OF GENERAL SERVICES.
DO NOT HAVE SPECIFIC EXPERTISE
IN THESE MATTERS.
THIS BILL WOULD ADD THE
SECRETARY OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY IS A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD WHEN IT IS CONSIDERING
MATTERS RELATED TO THE
ACQUISITION A PROPERTIES OR
CONSTRUCTION OF PROJECTS UNDER
THE JURISDICTION. OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY.
THE ADDITION OF THE SECRETARY
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES WILL
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD THAT CAN SPEAK TO THE
RESOURCES RELATED OR
CONSERVATION GOALS OF THE
PROJECT.
BECAUSE THE ADDITION OF THE
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES
WILL CREATE A BOARD WITH AN EVEN
NUMBER OF MEMBERS AND THE
POSSIBILITY OF A TIE VOTE. THE
BILL WILL PROVIDE THE
CHAIRPERSON OF THE BOARD OF THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE SHALL CAST
THE DECIDING VOTE UNDER SUCH A
CIRCUMSTANCE.
THE BILL WOULD NOT EXPAND THE
JURISDICTION OF THE BOARD IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD THE BILL IS UNLIKELY
TO CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF A
PROJECT UNDER CONSIDERATION. IT
WOULD HOWEVER AND SWORE THAT
THERE IS A ROBUST DISCUSSION OF
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES THEREFORE
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECALL MONSTER DID NOT A
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
OF THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND IS
A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION THAT
DOES A LOT OF LAND ACQUISITIONS
AND CERTAINLY HAS DONE A LOT OF
LAND ACQUISITIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WERE. YOU KNOW.
INTIMATELY AWARE OF THE.
VALUE OF THESE LANDS AND AND
AND THE IMPACTS.
ACQUISITIONS CAN HAVE OR
PROJECTS CAN HAVE IT MAKES
PERFECT SENSE TO ME THAT THE. A
PUBLIC WORKS BOARDED THAT
CONTEMPLATES LAND ACQUISITIONS
AND PAPA PROJECTS FOR THE
RESOURCES AGENCY SHOULD HAVE
RESOURCE EXPERTISE ON THE BOARD.
SO THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL BUT A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL SO WE URGE
YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOST OF THE MADE AND SECONDED.
SAYING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER BERMAN WHICH LIKE THOSE.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THING ALRIGHT AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I CHARGE
RECOMMENDATION IS AN AYE.
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE BY MEMBER BERMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ROUTE SWITCHING ON
THREATS RICHIE I ACOSTA.
ACOSTA BLOOM.
THOUGH I CHAU. CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
STONE.
SEVEN ZERO.
BELLOWS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MISTER E. GARCIA.
THIS IS ITEM.
NUMBER THREE AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE.
I THINK IT WAS CHAIR AND.
COLLEAGUES THAT I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A. B. NINETEEN FORTY.
FIVE THE BILL TO MAKE SOME MINOR
CHANGES TO THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION.
FUND.
SEVERAL YEARS INTO PROGRAMMING
THE TGIF. WE'VE LEARNED THAT.
WHAT WORKS AND WHAT ISN'T
WORKING UP FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ENSURING THAT THESE FUNDS?
REACH THE INTENDED AUDIENCES AND
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATIONS OF STATE.
MY DISTRICT LIKE MANY OF YOURS
OUR STAFF HAS BEEN LOT OF TIME
TALKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT. HOW TO
ACCESS THESE IMPORTANT
RESOURCES?
WHILE AT TIMES THE PROJECTS THAT
A PROPOSED ARE GOOD FITS FOR THE
PROGRAM.
OTHER FOLKS ARE JUST NOT
APPLYING IT COMPLAINING THAT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING A FAIR
SHAKE.
AT THESE DOLLARS.
OTHER TIMES APPLICANTS ARE
PUTTING IN THE WORK AND NOT
BEING SUCCESSFUL DO TO LIMIT
FUNDING AND THE WAY THE
APPLICATION'S GOING. PROCESS
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS
I ISSUES RELATED TO DENSITY
ABOUT BEING ONE OF THEM.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL MAKE SMALL
CHANGES THAT WILL MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR COMMUNITIES
ATTEMPTING TO COMPETE FOR THESE
RESOURCES.
AS FOR SPECIFIC AREAS.
THAT WRE ATTEMPTING TO CHANGE
IN THIS PROPOSAL FIRST WE'RE
EXPANDING THE LIST OF CO
BENEFITS THAT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD HAS BEEN DEVELOPING IN
CONSULTATION WITH ACADEMICS. AND
MINISTERING AGENCIES TO ENSURE
IT CAPTURES ALL OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT WE HAVE TO LINE THESE
INVESTMENTS WITH OTHER COMMUNITY
STATE PRIORITIES.
SECOND WE'RE DIRECTING THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO WORK WITH
AGENCIES TO ENSURE COMMUNITIES
IDENTIFIED FOR EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THOUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF AB SIX ONE
SEVEN I GIVE PREFERENCE FOR
RESOURCES AS WELL.
THE THIRD ARE ALLOWING OUR
BORDER REGIONS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S IMPERIAL AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. TO INCLUDE
DAYTIME POPULATIONS YOU SEE THAT
WE HAVE.
THE UNIQUE GEOGRAPHIC
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT THAT WE ARE
ADJACENT TO ANOTHER COUNTRY. AND
IN THE CASE OF A PRO COUNTY WE
HAVE A LITTLE OVER ONE MILLION.
PEOPLE A POPULATION THAT CROSS
OVER EVERY SINGLE DAY TO DO
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT'S THE THIRD CHANGE IN
THE FOURTH AND FINAL ARE
DIRECTING THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO START TRACKING
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED. FOR
FUNDING.
I SAID THE LEGISLATURE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE IS UNMET
FUNDING NEEDS AND THE BARRIERS
TO ACCESSING THOSE.
SUPPORT FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
REFINE THE DDR F. TO ENSURE IT
IS MEETING ITS INTENDED GOALS
AND WE CAN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED IT THE MOST.
I WANT TO THANK STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK IN ANALYZING THIS BILL AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT ALL THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. OF FOR THIS BILL WITH
ME TODAY IS THE OUTLAYS GROW
MEADOW WITH THE IMPAIR COUNTY
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EVA
METAL AND ASSIST THEIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICER WOULDN'T WITH
THE IMPRINT UNABLE TO CONTROL
THE DISTRICT.
I AM ALSO A LIFE LONG BILL
RESIDENT A BOTH IN FRONT COUNTY
MEXICALI MEXICO.
OKAY HOW FOR THEM TRUCK COUNTY
AND THEN BROKE ONLY A POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT I'M HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE THAT WILL
ENSURE FUNDING FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
REACHES COMMUNITIES SUFFERING
FROM CUMULATIVE POPULATION
BURDEN PURSUANT TO AB SEEKS
SEVENTEEN.
IT BURKE ON INCLUDE SEVERAL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND IS
ONE OF THE POOREST COUNTIES IN
THE STATE SUFFERING FOR IT ON
HEALTHY AND. UNHEALTHY AIR
POLLUTION IN MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE STATE'S RATE OF ASTHMA
RELATED EMERGENCY ROOMS VISITS
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR
CHILDREN.
IN BROAD CONNIE HAS BEEN
CLASSIFIED AS A FAN OF THEM I
PAYMENT AREA.
FOR DIFFERENT POLLUTANTS SUCH AS
PM TEN PM TWO POINT FIVE AND
OWES.
ONE OF IMPAIR COUNTIES UNIQUE
FEATURES IS ALSO ITS GREATEST
TALENTS WHEN TRYING TO IMPROVE
THEIR QUALITY.
IF PER COUNTY IS ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S INTERNATIONAL
GATEWAYS.
IN PARTICULAR THE CITY OF
CALEXICO SHARES A BORDER WITH A
THAT'S SILLY I PLAYED A CD OF
MEXICALI MEXICO.
THAT PROMOTE PRIMARY REASON FOR
ELEVATED OZONE AND BE AT THE
POINT HIGH LEVEL THINKING PER
COUNTY. IS THE MITCHELL TRUST
FOR FROM MEXICO.
THEN MEXICALI METROPOLITAN AREA
AS A POPULATION WELL OVER ONE
MILLION PEOPLE AS COMPARED WITH
THE SIGNIFICANTLY SMALL ANOTHER
CD OUT THAT CALEXICO THAT HAS A
POPULATION APPROXIMATELY FORTY
THOUSAND.
BECAUSE OF THESE DIFFERENCES
MEXICALI MITCHELL AFFECTING PER
COUNTY AND PARTICULARLY CALEXICO
AMBIENT OZONE AND PM TWO POINT
FIVE CRISIS AND A DAILY BASIS.
PREPARE COUNTY RESIDENTS IS VERY
COMMON TO EXPERIENCE TO PUT
THREE I WORK WAY LINE AT THE
INTERNATIONAL BORDER. THIS
INCLUDE THE SCHOOL BOND CHILDREN
EVERY CULTURAL FIT WORKERS AS
WELL AS CONSUMERS WHO HAD TO
ENDURE IS BURDENED DALY.
THERE AS THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND PERSONAL
VEHICLES AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEDESTRIANS ACROSS THE BORDER
NORTHBOUND INTO U. S. NO DAILY
BASIS AT THE IMPERIAL AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BORDER CROSSINGS.
THE BIG WILD PRICE SINCE I TO
THE IMPACT THE CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL ROADS AND STATE HIGHWAYS.
THIS ARE UNIQUE SAID BECAUSE
THAT'S SO THAT ONLY AND PACKED
AN INTERNATIONAL BORDER A
COMMUNITY LIKE OURS.
WHO IS FACED WITH THE CHALLENGE
TO SERVE AND SUPPORT SUCH A
LARGE POPULATION ON A DAILY
BASIS WHEN FUNDING IS BASED ON
OUR AND OUR COUNTY POPULATION OF
A HUNDRED EIGHTY? THOUSAND THEIR
PEOPLE.
THIS FUNDS WILL ENORMOUSLY
HELPING BROUGHT CONDUCT IMPROVE
EXISTING LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO BETTER SERVE THEIR COMMUNITY
AND REDUCE CONGESTION AND OUR
LOCAL ROADS WITH THE PURPOSE OF
IMPROVING THEIR QUALITY AND
GRIEF WINK OF GAS EMISSIONS.
BESIDES BEING A RESIDENT OF
MEXICALI AND IT BROKE ON ME ALL
MY LIFE. I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THE BALCONY POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT FOR ALL.
LIVID OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
WEEKS FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS.
I'VE BEEN HONORABLY DE BEEN THAT
CULTURE UNDER BY NATIONAL
BORDERS ANYTHING HE COMMITTEE SO
IF I.
S. REALIZING YOU ARE.
.
OVER YOUR TIME LIMIT IF OUTRIGHT
ELEMENT GIVING A CLOSING I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. AND WOULD
LIKE TO REAFFIRM A BILL COUNTY
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
FOR.
WE ARE REAL QUICK CHAIR MEMBERS
DOUG HOUSTON REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA PARK RECREATION
SOCIETY.
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
STATE PARKS PARTNERS COALITION.
TAHOE CITY PEEVED DE.
AND.
RAILS TO TRAILS.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION PARTICULARLY THAT
PIECE ON CO BENEFITS AND
PROMOTING COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC
ACCESS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A GOOD ADDITION
TO COPE BUT A MYTH CHO BENEFITS
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CAN GOOD AFTERNOON I RECALL
MUSTARD NOT A WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU.
MOTIONS MADE AND SECONDED FELL
OUT ANY FURTHER.
QUESTIONS MISTER GARCIA I. OR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS.
.
GO FORWARD I WHEN I FIRST HEARD
IT I I HAD SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE.
THE PROVISIONS RELATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER BUT
UPON SEEING VIA COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND SEEING THE NUMBERS.
LIKE.
WAS FULLY APPRECIATED THE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES FACING THE.
AB THE BORDER AREA AND SO I
WILL.
.
THE SUPPORTING IT BELL.
WITH AMENDMENTS WHICH YOU HAVE
FULLER EXCEPT WE WOULD ACCEPT IN
OUR.
WHICH LIKE CLOTHES THAT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION RESPECT
RASPBERRY HYPE THANK YOU.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL PLEASE ITEM THREE AB
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE BY EDUARDO
GARCIA THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING.
LIMON.
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
STONE.
FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO THE BILL'S
ON CALL.
NEXT WE HAVE MS AND YOUR CURRY
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN.
THIS IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
I WOULD TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS THEY HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED TO YOU TODAY.
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN WILL
PROMOTE HOLISTIC A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS LONG TERM
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT.
REDUCIBLE WILDFIRE RISKS BY
EXPANDING WOOD PRODUCT MARKETS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL INCENTIVIZE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN FOREST
HEALTH.
WHICH IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES.
PREVENT CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
DEVELOP RURAL ECONOMIES AND
PROMOTE OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
SPECIFICALLY AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN DEFINES MASS TIMBER AND
INNOVATIVE FOREST PRODUCTS IN
STATE LAW AND ASK HOW FAR TO
IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS BARRIERS TO
MARKET EXPANSION.
STATE ALONE CANNOT SUPPORT THE
REMOVAL OF WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY
KINDLING FOR FUTURE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES.
THIS BILL TAKES THE PARDON STEP
TO HELP PRIVATE INDUSTRIES
BECOME PARTNERS WITH THE STATE
IN PREVENTING WILDFIRES IN
PROMOTING HEALTHY FORESTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY KRISTIN
KOPEC ME FROM CALIFORNIA'S
ANALYSTS BOTH FORCED BROOK FROM
NATURE CONSERVANCY.
CARE SINGLE PICKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL ONE OF
THE MOST CRITICAL NEEDS FACING
OUR FORCES ADDRESSING WHAT TO DO
WITH ALL THE EXCESS YOU'LL AN
OVERSTOCK STANDS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE FOREST. AND BECAUSE OF
EMERGENCY WHERE IN WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO TURN AWAY SOLUTIONS
WHILE WE BELIEVE THAT BIOMASS IS
AN INTEGRAL COMPONENT OF ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS TO THE ISSUE OF
EXCESS FUELS. WE BELIEVE THAT
MASS TIMBER HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BE AN ADDITIONAL SOLUTION THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO CREATE A
VIABLE PRODUCT OF ONCE WAS
PREVIOUSLY IN UNMARKETABLE
MATERIAL. HISTORICALLY FORCE
HAVE HAD APPROXIMATELY FORTY
TREES PER ACRE MUCH OF
CALIFORNIA'S FORCE LANDS ARE NOW
WELL IN EXCESS OF A HUNDRED
TREES PER ACRE WHILE THERE ARE
TOO MANY TREES. WHEN ARE TOO
MANY TREES THEY COMPETE FOR
RESOURCES DROUGHT STRESSES THESE
TREES AND MANY DIRE BECOME
VULNERABLE TO VULNERABLE TO
INSECT ATTACKED. THAT'S WHY
THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION DEAD TREES IN OUR
FOR US TODAY.
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
ENCOURAGE NEW INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS AND PRODUCTS THAT CAN
SIMULTANEOUSLY INCREASE THE
HEALTH AND RESILIENCY. OF OUR
FOR FOR OVER FOREST'S CAL FORCES
READY TO SUPPORT WE ASK FOR A
VOTE.
IF YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS LESS FORCE PROGRAM
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN. I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK SO REMEMBER AT
YOUR CURRY FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE.
SO I STATED WILDFIRES YOU GET
LARGER AND MORE DESTRUCTIVE IN A
MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO THESE.
INCREASE THESE MEGA FIRES IS
OVERLY DENSE FOREST
WHICH ARE OVERGROWN WITH SMALL
DIAMETER TREES DEAD AND DYING
TREES AND WHAT IF I AM.
GREATER INVESTMENT IS IN
ECOLOGICALLY BASED THINNING AND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IS NEEDED.
AND ONE WAY TO INCREASE
INVESTMENT FORCE RESTORATION IS
TO EXPAND THE WHAT PRODUCTS
MARKET TO UTILIZE THIS MATERIAL
REMOVED FROM THE FOREST.
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN DOES
JUST THAT THE BILL PROMOTES
MARKETS FOR NEW INNOVATIVE
FOREST PRODUCTS THAT WOULD USE
THE BLOODY MATERIAL FROM FORCE
RESTORATION PROJECTS.
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN
RECOGNIZES THE CRITICAL NEED TO
EXPAND THE USE FOR WHAT PRODUCTS
FOR PROMOTING FOREST HEALTH AND
PROMOTING EEK ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA LAST LANCE FORSTER
SOCIALIZATION AND ALSO THE FORCE
LICENSE.
OF CALIFORNIA WERE IN SUPPORT
THE BILL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING MISS AMERICA IAN WITH A
FORK.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
MCKAY THE ON BEHIND MY BEHALF OF
HUMBLE MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANIES OLSON'S OF.
GOOD AFTERNOON CORRIE BOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BREEZY SULLIVAN
SALAS POTTER BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA TAHOE ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS TRY
ROBERT SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ERIK KARLSSON ASSOCIATING
CALIFORNIA LOGGERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OCCUPY THE TWO FRONT SEATS HERE.
A ALUMINUM STE SHARE.
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TIM PAYING
ABOVE ST THINK THE NATIONAL
READY MIX CONCRETE ASSOCIATION.
AND I THINK.
TO COMMITTEE FOR THE UP TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL
UNLESS AMENDED.
THEN I'M CA A A PLUS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE FOR
EXPLORING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INNOVATION.
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENTS.
WHILE MANAGING TO USE NATURAL
RESOURCES BUT. THERE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS OF THE BILL REGARDING
ITS ASSUMPTIONS.
ESPECIALLY OF REGARDING MASS
TIMBER AND I'VE WRITTEN.
.
PUTTING TESTIMONY CORRECT SUMMIT
IT UP BUT I'LL MAKE FOUR POINTS
HERE.
ONE IS THAT THE SCIENCE DOESN'T
SUPPORT THE REMOVAL OF DEAD
TREES.
AMONG SCIENTISTS.
THERE'S OLD OVERWHELMING
CONSENSUS THAT THE DENSITY OF
BIOMASS DOES NOT DETERMINE HOW
WILDLAND FIRES. A BEHAVE.
RESEARCHES AT NATIONAL ACADEMY
OF SCIENCES OREGON STATE
UNIVERSITY. UNIVERSITY OF
VERMONT FOUND THE FORCE WERE
HIGH SNAG LEVELS ACTUALLY TEND
TO BURN LESS INTENSELY THAN OF
THE FOREST.
A MORE WITH THIS NAGGING WOODY
BIOMASS CONTRIBUTE TO THE FORCE
REJUVENATION AND BECOMES MICHAEL
HABITATS FOR WILDLIFE.
SECOND A MASS TIMBER IS A
COMBUSTIBLE FIRE RISK.
MASTABA BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN
IMPLIED.
IN MUCH LITERATURE AND
ADVERTISING IT BEHAVES LIKE FIRE
RESISTIVE MATERIAL.
A INTO FIVE DOING FIRED DUE TO
ITS HIRING LAYER. BUT A UNLIKE
FIRE RESISTIVE MATERIALS THE
COMBUSTIBLE TIMBER ACTUALLY
CONTRIBUTES TO THE FIRE LOW
ACCELERATING THE FLASH OVER.
SO MASTABA STRUCTURES ARE
UNLIKELY TO SURVIVE THE FIERY
EVENT.
M. WILL HAVE TO BE DEMOLISHED
AFTER THE FIRE.
BUT THE THIRD POINT IS.
MASS TIMBER IS A JOB CREATORS
DOT PROVEN.
BUT THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT NEW
MASS TIMBER PRODUCTS NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND
EFFICIENCIES.
A IN WOOD MANUFACTURING HAVE
DISPLACED JOBS.
INTO WOULDN'T SEE NOT THE LACK
OF COMMAND.
OF FINALLY.
SUPPORTING. INNOVATION IS
CERTAINLY ADMIRABLE OF BUT THE
BILL IS A ZERO SUM GAME
ECONOMICALLY.
IT SEEKS TO PROTECT JOBS IN ONE
SECTOR WHILE AT THE EXPENSE OF
OTHERS WORKING IN DIFFERENT
SECTORS WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
PROVIDING ARTIFICIAL BENEFIT TO
ONE MATERIAL CAN ONLY BE JUST A
VALUE OF CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
IN THE STATE.
AND WE BELIEVE LEGISLATION THAT
USE TAX DOLLARS.
TO DECIDE WINNERS OR LOSERS IN
THE CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS
INDUSTRY ARM.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
TOM TEATS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA SMITH
ASSOCIATION. I WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
LISTENING TO SOME OF OUR
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE OFFERED
AND. IT REALLY AND MY COURAGE BY
THAT DIALOGUE.
WHEN THING WE APPLY IT IS THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL. WE BELIEVE
THAT ADDRESSING A WILDFIRE
ISSUES IS VERY IMPORTANT AS WELL
AS RURAL JOB CREATION.
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR INDUSTRY WE
HAVE A LOT OF RURAL.
.
PLANTS AND FEEL THAT'S OF
IMPORTANT PLACE TO FOCUS.
WE ALSO AS TEN MENTIONED ARE OUR
PRODUCERS OF NON COMBUSTIBLE
BUILDING MATERIALS.
WHICH WE THINK IS IMPORTANT PART
OF THE SOLUTION MOVING FORWARD.
THE REASON WHY WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL UNLESS AMENDED.
IS THAT LIKE I MENTIONED EARLIER
WE FEEL IT'S NOT THE PLACE OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO PICK
FAVORITES.
WHEN IT COMES TO BUILDING
MATERIALS.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL
SHOULD BE DONE THROUGH THE CODES
PROCESS
AND INDIVIDUAL DESIGN.
ENTITIES.
AND LASTLY WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS
OUTLINED IN TERMS OF USING MASS
TIMBER AND SOME OF THESE.
INNOVATIVE BUILDING THAT
MATERIALS.
FOR SOLUTIONS USING THAT WOULD.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
RECOMMENDED BY SOME OF THE
REPORTS THAT HAVE SUBMITTED BEEN
SUBMITTED TO CAL FIRE. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT.
.
IT WOULD BE SEEN THE RANKINGS IN
TERMS OF FEASIBILITY AND DON'T
NECESSARILY BELIEVE THIS IS THE
RIGHT TYPE OF SOLUTION MOVING
FORWARD. BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS BILL
MOVING AHEAD. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
CHARLIE RAY CALIFORNIA TO
DESTRUCTION DUSTER MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION WRIST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE WASN'T.
JULIE TRUST BUT THE CALIFORNIA
MASON CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
ALTA ALSO WITHIN OPPOSE A LAST
MINUTE DECISION.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER WITNESSES
COMING FORWARD ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE.
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
I ADMIT I WAS HERE FOR THE
ENTIRE PRESENTATION. A HONEST
DEBATE A MOTION AT THIS POINT.
THE.
JUNE SECOND OKAY JUST ONE IT HAS
NOT BEEN SECONDED SET SECOND.
.
AND AGAIN I'M SORRY THAT I HAD
TO LEAVE THE FOR THE LAST
PRESENTATION FROM MYSTERY GARCIA
AS WELL BECAUSE I THINK US WHEN
THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT ONE
WERE.
STATE IS BECAUSE WE ARE I AM WE
AND WE THAT HAVE AS MANY ISSUES
AS WE HAVE I THINK WE NEED TO BE
AS CREATIVE AS WE CAN TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THEM.
AND HAVING MARKETS FOR ALL THAT
TIMBER AND ALL THE BIOMASS STEP
THAT WE BRING OUT REPRESENTING
AND AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT. IF
WE'RE NOT DOING SOMETHING WITH
IT THEN THERE'S OPEN FIRES AND
IT JUST CONTINUES TO ACCUMULATE
OR END UP IN OUR WE STREAM WHICH
IS NOT THE PLACE FOR IT.
FROZEN TREAT WITH THE LAST BILL.
AND I CAN I THINK YOU'RE ON TO
SOMETHING HERE TO HAVE ALSO DONE
SOMETHING WOOD WOOD PRODUCTS WE
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ENCOURAGE.
PEOPLE TO USE THIS THAT THAT
THAT THE TRASH THAT WE HAVE THE
WASTE THAT WE HAVE OTHERWISE IT
JUST GOES INTO OUR ATMOSPHERE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
HAVE A QUESTION FOR.
THE.
.
CEMENT INDUSTRY.
REPRESENTATIVES HOW HOW HOW
DOES. THAT THE TIMBER PRODUCTS.
REPLACE OR COMPETE WITH.
CEMENT PRODUCTS.
OUR ALL STAR.
.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY IS THE THEY ARE
PROMOTINGIT AS A REPLACEMENT TO.
COMBUSTIBLE NON COMBUSTIBLE
CONSTRUCTION
WHETHER ITS STEEL OR CONCRETE.
IN TERMS OF HIGH RISES IN TERMS
OF ALL THE PUBLIC BUILDINGS.
THAT IS HOW THE MASS TIMBER IS
BEING PROMOTED.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
.
IS THAT YOUR CURRY I THINK A.
WE ARE PROPOSING MAKES TO ME
THAT THE.
WE HAVE A WILDFIRE CRISIS.
TRYING TO.
INCENTIVIZE DECLARING OF ACCESS.
TIMBER.
THAT IS.
CORD DELIVER HOOVER COMMISSION
HAS BEEN.
.
FEEDING THE. OVERABUNDANCE OF
SMALL DAMAGE TREES AND OTHER
WOOD MATERIALS THAT INCREASE
SURFER FUELS A FEEL FOR.
FEEDING
FEED FIRES.
SO I WILL BE. RECOMMENDING AYE
VOTE ON ON YOUR BILL WHICH LIKE
CLOSE.
AGAIN THIS BILL TAKES IMPORTANT
STEP TO HELP PRIVATE INDUSTRIES
BECOME PARTNERS WITH THE STATE
AND PREVENTING WILDFIRES AND
PROVOKE PREVENT. PROMOTING HIS
HIS MEAN HEALTHY FOREST
IN NO WAY. DOES THIS BILL AVOID
SAFETY TESTING FOR STANDARDS IN
STATE LAW OR REGULATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOTIONS MADE
AND SECONDED ROLL CALL.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN BY MEMBER AGUIAR CURRY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAU.
EGGMAN PIPE EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA MON. MCCARTY. MELENDEZ
STONE.
FOUR ZERO.
FOR SURE THE BILLS ON CALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IF.
NEXT WE HAVE MS FREED MEN.
THIS IS.
BY OF NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN.
ANOTHER FIRE SAFETY. YES THANK
YOU CHAIR MURATSUCHI AND
MEMBERS.
WOULD YOU LIKE THE LONG VERSION
OR THE SHORT VERSION.
SURE SHORT IS OKAY YEAH.
THROUGH THE CHAIR I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE STOP
FOR THEIR HELP ON AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENT TO SUGGEST IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
IT'S BECOME INCREASINGLY HERE
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS THAT
WILDFIRE SEASON IS A YEAR ROUND
ROUND BATTLE.
AND THAT WE NEED TO RE EVALUATE
AND ADJUST OUR CURRENT POLICIES
AND REGULATIONS.
A LITTLE. TOO NINE ONE ONE IS AN
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT CITIES
FOUND WITHIN HIGH FIRED HOWSER
SEVERITY ZONES AND STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS HAVE THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO PREVENT AND
REDUCE THE RISK OF WILDFIRES. AB
TWO NINE ONE ONE SIX TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO FIRE SAFETY
PLANNING EFFORTS AND LOCAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES STRENGTHENED
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS.
AND CLARIFY VEGETATION CLEAR
CLEARANCE ROOM
ACQUIREMENT AROUND UTILITY LINES
ALL WHITE PROMOTING HABITAT
RESTORATION AND THE USE OF
NATIVE PLANTS.
GIVEN THAT IS THE DEVASTATION OF
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRE SEASON IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE REEVALUATED UPDATE
CURRENT FIRE SAFETY MEASURES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME FOR.
MR MEMBERS CAN CAST WITH SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC WE DO NOT
HAVE A FORMAL SUPPORT POSITION
ON THE BILL WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS THAT WERE THANKED OUT
THE FOR WORKING WITH US.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IS A KEY
COMPONENT DEALING WITH WELFARE
SITUATION WE'RE FACING AND LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON PALMETTO PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BILL. I'D LIKE THAT TO
EXPRESS APPRECIATION NOT JUST OF
INNOVATION MANAGEMENT BELL
WITHIN A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT THE CONDITION OF THE
FOREST WHICH ABSOLUTELY NEEDS. A
LOT OF ATTENTION AND SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES OUR
APPROACHING AT. BUT JUST
REDUCING FIRE THREATS OUT ON THE
LANDSCAPE DOES NOT SOLVE OUR
PROBLEM IF WE KEEP BUILDING
HOMES AND PLACES IN IN WAYS THAT
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO BURN ONE
OF IS A BAD WEATHER EVENTS SO WE
NEED TO GET SMARTER ABOUT
PLANNING. SMARTER ABOUT
HARDENING OF THE HOMES ARE
ALREADY AT BILL ON THE LANDSCAPE
THIS BILL TAKES USEFUL STEPS IN
BOTH OF THOSE DIRECTIONS VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY OPEN
I'M SORRY O. PARDON ME WHEN YOU
LOOK AND WE MEMBERS. OF RICOH
MONSTER TO NOT A WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND AND SPUR.
CAMPAIGNING NATIONAL BUT MAKES
CONCRETE ASSOCIATIONS.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MUCH HAS BEEN MADE IS OUR
SECOND.
MS FRIEDMAN WHICH I CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. GOSH THAT'S BEEN MADE
AND SECONDED CHOSE
RECOMMENDATION AS I.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
BY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT SEARCHING AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING.
LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S
STONE.
THREE ZERO GRAZER THE BILL'S ON
CALL AND THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT NEXT WE HAVE.
OR IS SHE.
OH YES MS RAYOS ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN WILL
ENSURE THAT CRITICAL STEPS ARE
TAKEN THROUGH SEQUEL PROCESS.
TRULY ENGAGE COMMUNITIES WHICH
CURRENTLY SHOULDER THE UNDUE
BURDEN OF POLLUTION.
THE CORE MESSAGE TO THIS BILL A
SIMPLE. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
PRIORITIZE BRINGING THE MOST
VULNERABLE GROUPS TO IN THE
STATE TO THE TABLE WHEN MAKING
LOCAL LAND USE DECISIONS.
CALMAR SCREEN CURRENTLY IN A
THREE POINT OVER ZHAN IS A TOOL
THAT ALLOWS US TO BETTER
RECOGNIZE LINKAGES.
BETWEEN ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION AND POVERTY IN ORDER
TO INFORM DECISION DECISION
MAKERS. AND THE PUBLIC.
IF WE KNOW THAT AREAS WITHIN
THESE COMMITTEES ARE NOT ONLY
POLLUTED BUT ALSO MAY STRUGGLE
TO BE ENGAGED IN THE TRADITIONAL
SICK WERE PROCESS. GIVEN
BARRIERS IN PLACE FOR PEOPLE OF
LOW INCOME. PUBLIC POLICY SHOULD
DO EVERYTHING IT CAN TO ENGAGE
THEM IN THE PLANNING PROCESS.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A STEP TO
ENSURE THAT AND WHAT CAN BE A
CONFUSING PROCESS THE VOICES OF
ALL COMMUNITIES ARE HEARD.
I KNOW THIS IS NOT A SIMPLE BILL
AND THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PROVISIONS CURRENTLY BEING
REFINED.
SO THERE ARE A FEW THINGS I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE CLEAR. THIS
BILL IS NOT MEANT TO INCLUDE
HOUSING.
ALTHOUGH AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN IS LABELED A HOUSING
KILLER I AM WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
INCLUDING ANY TYPE OF
RESIDENTIAL. DEVELOPMENT WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL BILLS
REQUIREMENTS IS NOT ITS INTENT.
MY STAFF HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND THE BEST
WAY TO HONE THE SCOPE OF A
SUBJECT LAND USE PROJECT.
WE'RE ALSO IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE WHAT
THEIR INTERPRETATION OF THE
STATUTE AS WRITTEN WOULD BE WHEN
DEVELOPING A LIST OF SUBJECT
LAND USES.
OUR LAST AMENDMENTS BEGAN THE
PROCESS OF NARROWING THE SCOPE.
QUALIFY PROJECTS
AND THROUGH FURTHER DIALOGUE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT NO PROJECT
SHOULD INTENTIONALLY
DISCRIMINATE. BUT AS AN ATTORNEY
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE LEGAL
DIFFICULTIES THIS SECTION OF THE
BILL IN PRINT MAY CAUSE.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FINE TUNE THIS
PROVISION TO ADDRESS LEGAL
CONCERNS.
MEMBERS AND.
THE CHAIR YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
THAT THESE ARE ISSUES THAT I
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING.
AS YOU WILL HEAR DESPITE
CONCERNS WITH THE CURRENT BILL
WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGING WITH
OPPOSITION IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT WE ARE CLOSE.
TO FINDING COMMON GROUND THAT
WILL ACCOMPLISH MY STATED GOAL
OF ENGAGING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
WITH THAT WITHOUT A HERE WITH ME
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL
ARE LEO MISIA'S.
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT CURRENTLY
RESIDING IN A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY. AND ASHLEY WARNER.
SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
PRESENT HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF WHY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE TO CIRCLE
HAVE LEVEES LEGISLATURE LIKE AB
TWENTY SEVEN. TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN PASSED TO PROTECT THEIR
HEALTH HOME AND NEIGHBORHOOD.
MY NAME IS LEO MARTINEZ MUSAEUS
I'M A PROUD HOMEOWNER IN FRESNO
COUNTY AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MY COMMUNITY. A
COMMUNITY IS OF CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE FACED WITH THE SAME PROBLEM.
WHEN I PAT PURCHASE MY HOMIE
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN I DREAM OF
RACE IN MY FAMILY IN A CLEAN
SAFE. COMMUNITY WHERE MY
CHILDREN GROW GRANDCHILDREN GROW
UP TO FULFILL THEIR POTENTIAL.
HOWEVER MY DREAM HAS ERODED OVER
THE YEARS.
ALL VARIETIES OF INDUSTRIAL
PLANTS AND HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES PRONG UP AROUND MY
COMMUNITY.
BRING IT TOXIC AIR POLLUTION
CONCEPT TRUCK TRAFFIC.
AND CONTENT CONTAMINATING OUR
WATER.
WE WERE NEVER CONSULTED OR ASK
BEFORE THEIR FACILITIES UP HERE
AND STARTED TO IMPACT OUR
QUALITY OF LIFE. NOW OUR
COMMUNITY RATES IN THE HUNDRED
PERCENTILE FOR POLLUTION BURDEN
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA EPA.
BOTH MY SON AND I ALMOST ALL OF
MY NEIGHBORS HAVE EXPERIENCED
CANCER WHICH WE HAVE.
WHICH WE THINK.
HAVE TO DO WITH THAT TACTIC
CONTAMINANTS INTO AARON TO SOIL
AND THE WATER.
TO MAKE MATTER WORSE THE PAST
YEAR. THAT HALF OF THE FIFTIES
ME TO MAKE IT WOULDN'T HAVE
WORKED OUT A.
YEARS THE YEAR AND A HALF FRESNO
CD HAS APPROVED MILLIONS OF THE
FEET A INDUSTRIAL WAREHOUSES.
SPACE ACROSS THE STREET FROM MY
NEIGHBORHOOD AND NEAR LOCAL
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. WE WERE NEVER
TOLD ABOUT THIS PROJECT WHILE
THE CD WAS PLANNING THEM. NOW
THE DUSK I'M TO CONSTRUCT
INITIAL CAN OUR AIR ENTRY WHERE
IN OUR PAST.
WE ARE TOLD THERE MORE THAN
THOUSANDS A TRUCK BILL PASSED BY
OUR HOOPS EVERY DAY BUT NOT WHAT
WILL BE DONE. TO ENSURE THAT OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD KIDS CAN WALK AND
BIKE SAFELY OR TO KEEP OUR
AIRPLANE IN OUR HOMES. WE WERE
FEAR CONSEQUENCES OF THE PROJECT
ON OUR WATER SUPPLY IN ARTICLES
WE RELY ON SHALLOW DOMESTIC
WELLS. AND ALL OF OUR NEIGHBOR'S
WELLS WENT DRY DOING THEIR
DROUGHT.
BUT NO ONE ASKED US ABOUT THESE
WHEN DEPRIVED TO VOTE THE BALLOT
AND NO PROTECTION IT SEES. TO
ENSURE WE WILL NOT WILL. LOSE
WATER IN OUR HOMES WITH ALL OF
THESE.
CONDITIONS ARE BECOME IS SO BAD
I FEAR OUR FAMILY FINALLY.
YOU MAY NEED TO HAVE AND OUR
GREEN. AT WAS BORN BACK IN
NINETEEN TEXAS I WON I PURCHASED
BY WHOM AT THE VERY LEAST FOR
PROJECTS THAT CAN'T DO HARM
PUBLIC HEALTH AND UNDERMINE OUR.
NEIGHBORHOODS QUALITY OF HOLE OF
HOMES DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
LIKE BY.
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO A
PUBLIC PROCESS IN WHICH ARE
IMPERFECT QUESTIONS CONCERNED
SUGGESTIONS OR TAKEN IN
CONSIDERATION WHICH IT RECEIVED.
A DIRECT NOTICE FROM IN
LANGUAGES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
SPIRIT WE WOULD GET START TO
KNOW WHAT WILL BE BUILT IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
HOW IT WILL AFFECT US THIS IS
SOMETHING HAD ALL CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO AGREE ON I HAD
PUT HIS SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY ABOUT WHY MY ORGANIZATION
AND ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE
STATE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY SEVEN.
MY NAME IS ASHLEY WARNER AND I'M
A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH IS THIS
BILL SPONSOR.
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WORKS
ALONGSIDE HUNDREDS OF RESIDENTS
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
ANNE'S COACHELLA VALLEY'S
ADVOCATE FOR SOUND POLICY AND A
RADICALLY INJUSTICE. TO SECURE
EQUAL ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY
REGARDLESS OF WEALTH RACE INCOME
IN PLACE.
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IS ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
ALONG WITH THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY IN THE FIREMEN. WERE
ALSO HERE TODAY AND CAN SPEAK TO
THE NEED FOR AND MERIT OF THIS
BILL AS WELL.
WE KNOW FROM OUR EXPERIENCE AND
OUR WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMMUNITIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THAT LEO STORY IS JUST ONE OF
MANY STORIES WERE NEIGHBORHOODS
HEALTH WELL BEING AND PUBLIC
VOICE.
IT'S SUBJUGATED TO DEVELOPMENT
WITH SERIOUS ADVERSE IMPACTS.
WHERE STATE LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE
PUBLIC NOTICE OR MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INPUT? THE
VOICES OF THOSE RESIDENTS STAY
SILENT AND SO TO THEIR CONCERNS.
AS HAVE UNHEALTHY DEVELOPMENT
HAPPENS NEXT TO SCHOOLS NEXT A
HOMES CHILDCARE CENTERS PARKS
AND YOUR HOUSES OF WORSHIP
WITHOUT MEANINGFUL OF
MITIGATION.
THAT'S WE PERPETUATE
DISPROPORTIONATE POLLUTION
BURDENS DISPROPORTIONATE RATES
OF ACUTE AND CHRONIC ILLNESS AND
DISEASE AND SHORTER AVERAGE LIFE
EXPECTANCIES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN WOULD
ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES TO
LEARN ABOUT AND PROVIDE INPUT ON
PROJECTS THAT MAY IMPACT THEIR
HEALTH NEIGHBORHOODS AND HOMES.
AS LEO STATED IN HIS COMMENTS I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS GOOD POLICY
THAT ALL OF US IN CALIFORNIA CAN
AGREE ON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL.
POSTED TO ON BEHALF OF CENTER ON
REYES POP FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
STRONG SUPPORT THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON UNIVERSES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ROOM TO
JUST THE VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND THANK YOU FOR THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL. AND ALSO BE HAVE THE
CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
RICOH MUSTERED ANOTHER WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND THAT
SUPPORT.
ESTHER FESTIVELY ANY WITH
CALIFORNIA WALKS IN SUPPORT.
FRANCISCO AMEND THIS I LIVING IN
SOUTHWEST PERSONAL AND I AM IN
SUPPORT FOR THE SPIEL.
ACCORDING.
TO THE EPA. AND.
CALL IMPAIRMENT SCREEN NINE
THREE SEVEN OR SEEKS SEAT
BECAUSE OF WHERE I LIVE. IS
WHERE MANY INDUSTRIES.
ARE TRYING TO BUILD WITHOUT
LADIES ANNOUNCED NO. WE'VE NEVER
RECEIVED ANY NOTICE FOR AT NEXT
BUILDING FOR THE LAST TWENTY
FOUR YEARS. ALSO NOBODY A TRY TO
MEET WITH US TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
SO I AM SUPPORT FOR PLEASE
APPEAL A SO ARE YOU ON THAT WE
HOPE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ALEXANDER
HUNTING WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AS A. LEADER
IN AFFORDABLE AND FAIR HOUSING
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THING.
CAN I AM UNDESERVEDLY BY.
SORRY.
AND A SUPPLY THIS BILL BECAUSE
OUR COMMUNITIES IS SAID TO BE
INFORMED BEFORE OF THE SINGER'S
CLEAR IRON FIELDS. BANG OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MATTHEW BIGGER CLEANING
CONSERVATION THAT WE HAVEN'T
TAKEN A FORMAL POSITION ON THIS
BILL WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSION
ABOUT MINOR REFINEMENTS TO THE
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE BUT WE DO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE INTENT.
WHO IN THE COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION IN SUPPORT?
ACCORDING BLOSSOMED AFTER THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THREE MAIN WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH.
CHAIR MURATSUCHI AND REST
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ADAM
RIGHTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY EXPRESSING MY
APPRECIATION FOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND HER
STAFF THEY WORKED DILIGENTLY
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS.
BUT WE STILL HAVE SOME ISSUES
WITH THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN AND I WANTED TO.
IN KNOWLEDGE YOUR POINT ABOUT
THE ISSUE WITH.
.
THE.
INTENTIONAL DISCRIMINATION
ASPECT OF THIS BILL.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE
AGREE THAT LAND USE POLICIES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
INTENTIONALLY DISCRIMINATE.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE DO
THAT.
SEQUEL BY ITS VERY NATURE IS A
BILL OR EXCUSE ME THE STATUTE
INTENDED TO ADDRESS TANGIBLE AND
VERIFIABLE. ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS FROM PROPOSED PROJECTS
THIS BILL RADICALLY EXPAND SEEK
WERE TO ADDRESS IMPACTS THAT ARE
NOT QUANTIFIABLE. BE REALLY FOR
SLEEP AGENCIES TO
DETERMINE THE INTENT.
AND IT BE A FACT AT A STAGE IN
WHICH.
IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO DO.
SEE WERE. A. IS NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO ALLOW FOR THE AGENCIES
TO DEFEND A HIGHLY SUBJECTIVE
FINDING SUCH AS.
DISCRIMINATE.
INTO ACTUAL DISCRIMINATION.
OR DISCRIMINATORY EFFECT.
AND WILL LEAD TO EXCESSIVE
STEEPLE LITIGATION.
WE ALSO OFFICIALLY OPPOSE AB TWO
FOUR FOUR SEVEN BECAUSE THE
GIVES DISCRETION STATE AGENCIES
WITH LITTLE OR NO LAND USE UP
POLICY EXPERIENCE.
LAND USE IS A LOCAL CREATURE
BECAUSE A LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE
THE GREATEST KNOWLEDGE AS TO
WHAT IMPACT THE COMMUNITY AND
THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND FINALLY WE OPPOSE THE
CURRENT DEFINITION OF PROJECT AS
IN THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S
AMBIGUOUS AND LIKELY LEADS TO
FURTHER LITIGATION OVER HOW WE
DEFINE WHAT PROJECT IS UNDER
SEEK WELL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CASSIE GILSON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
I'M FOR SOMEONE I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
REACHING OUT WAS VERY EARLY IN
THE YEAR AND FOR THEIR ROBUST
ENGAGEMENT WITH US THROUGHOUT
THE DISCUSSIONS ON THE BILL
TODAY. I'M CERTAINLY IF WE'RE
ABLE TO AGREE ON AMENDMENTS THAT
REMOVE HOUSING FROM THE BILL IT
WOULD COME OFF OF HOUSING KILLER
LIST. AND IT WOULD LEAVE US WITH
SOME OF THAT MACABRE BROADER
SEQUEL POLICY CONCERNS THAT ARE
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF TO RESOLVE
THOSE GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARYANN WARMER DAM UP
THE REAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA.
.
LIKE THE OTHERS WE DO APPRECIATE
MS RAY THIS IS WORKING WITH LAST
SUMMER HOPEFUL WE MIGHT FIND AN
ACCOMMODATION. BUT WE BELIEVE
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN IS
ADDING ADDITIONAL PROCESS WHICH
IN OUR EXPERIENCE. DOESN'T LEAD
TO A BETTER OUTCOME AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
PROJECTS GENERALLY ARE WELL
NOTICED WITHIN A COMMUNITY SO
WE'RE HOPEFUL WE CAN FIND. AN
INTERSECTION OF OUR IN TRUSTS IN
GOOD LAND USE POLICY AND THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
COMMUNICATION BUT REGRETFULLY
MUST CONTINUE TO BE A POST AT
THIS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A LEGACY
FOR THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
FOR SOME OF THE. REASONS STATED
BUT ALSO LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR ON.
PERHAPS FINDING SOME
COMBINATION.
YEAH COVERAGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS ALSO
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION BUT
CONCERNED WITH HOW THIS MIGHT
IMPACT HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AS EGGMAN.
YEAH I THINK YOU AND THANK YOU
MISTRESS FOR THAT BUT THE
PRESENTATION. AND THE.
ATTENTION TO THIS IS YOU I ALSO
REPRESENT AN AREA THAT HAS A
LARGE DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITY
COMPONENT TO IT.
AND.
AND EXPERIENCE MYSELF WE WE HAVE
VARIOUS SMELLS AT CIRCLE OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD WE LIVE CLOSE TO
PORT AND INDUSTRIAL AREAS SO
IT'S PART OF. OUR LIVES AND AND
WE DO A LOT OF BETH INTERNAL
COMMUNICATION.
I'M GONNA MOVE THIS BILL TODAY
AND I'M I'M HOPING TO GET IT CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON WITH THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
WE ARE ALSO FACING A HOUSING
CRISIS. AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT ARE OUR BEST LAID PLANS.
DON'T GET THE WAY OF OUR OTHER.
VERY HIGH GOALS THAT WE NEED TO
WORK TOWARD SO I TRUST EVEN
CONTINUE WORK ON THIS AND FIND A
WAY TO. TO THREAD THAT NEEDLE.
BECAUSE CERTAINLY PEOPLE'S LIFE
EXPECTANCY SHOULD NOT BE BASED
ON THERE'S A COAT.
AS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
.
WHAT MS RAISE IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE TRYING TO WORK THROUGH?
ALL THE DIFFERENT.
CONCERNS I HAVE BEEN RAISED BUT
I'D.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS I'M HOPING
YOU CAN ADD SOME CLARITY TO FOR
ME.
.
WHAT I'M READING SAYS THAT
ESSENTIALLY?
A FULL BLOWN  I ARE WOULD
HAVE TO BE DONE FOR BASICALLY
EVERY PROJECT THAT NO NEGATIVE
DECLARATIONS WOULD BE ACCEPTED
WHICH.
IS PROBLEMATIC AS YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND IS THAT YOUR INTENT.
IN THIS BILL.
AT THE BILL DOES NOT STATE THAT
AND. IS THERE A SPECIFIC
PROVISION THAT I'M.
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO.
SO AND AND JUST TO CLARIFY SO
WHAT THE BILL DOES YEAH THE PART
THAT SAYS HE BASED YOU'D HAVE
TO.
I MEET ALL THE STANDARDS SO THAT
YOU WOULD GET TO THE POINT WHERE
HE WOULDN'T EVEN REALLY BE ABLE
TO ACCEPT A NEGATIVE.
DECORATION.
I'M WILL AT THE BILL CERTAINLY
WOULD ALLOW NEGATIVE DECLARATION
AS LONG AS IT'S YOU KNOW
APPROPRIATE AND THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE THE LA ON THAT IT
REQUIRES.
NOTICE AND A SCOPING MEETING
I'M REGARDLESS OF WHETHER A
NEGATIVE DECLARATION OR ANY ARE
IT'S BEING PREPARED.
OKAY SO.
.
THAT IS A GOOD POINT WITH A FAIR
ARGUMENT STATEMENT CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE THAT SEEMS
TO BE HOW ONE WOULD BE ABLE TO
STOP.
THIS PROJECT FROM GOING FORWARD
OR AT LEAST FORCING A FULL III
ARE. IT IT DOES NOT MODIFY THE
STANDARDS UNDER WHICH AND A
NEGATIVE DECLARATION VERSUS AN
YEAH ARE WOULD HAVE TO BE
PREPARED AND SO I WAS DOING IS
ALLOWING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESIDENTS TO PROVIDE THEIR INPUT
ABOUT WHAT TYPES OF IMPACTS
MILLION TO STAY IN THE AFTER
YOU'RE NOT ADDRESSING THE. FEAR
STANDARD STATEMENT THAT I ASKED
I'D I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND
THE QUESTION.
OKAY IT'S OKAY WE CAN DISCUSS
PERHAPS FURTHER ADAM OFFLINE.
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE THOUGH
IS IT SAYS YOU.
.
ONE MAKE SURE THE PROJECT WILL
NOT INTENTIONALLY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST A PROTECTED CLASS OR
RESULT IN A DISCRIMINATORY
EFFECT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
WELL AND AND IF YOU'D LIKE IT'S
SIMPLY REFERENCING EXISTING LAW
SO IT'S NOT CREATING YOU LIE
THIS IS A LOT OF THE
JURISDICTIONS MUST COMPLY WITH
NOW ANYWAYS AND. AND SO IT
SIMPLY HIGHLIGHTING THAT.
EXISTING LEGAL OBLIGATION BUT AM
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED
THAT IS A PROVISION THAT'S UNDER
DISCUSSION I'M FOR POTENTIAL
CHANGE.
OKAY.
COME.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MISTER GLOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE ON THIS BILL I WANT
TO ASSOCIATE MY. THAT.
FEELINGS ABOUT THIS WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY MS
EGGMAN.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
YOU'RE INTENDING TO AMEND THE
BILL TO EXCLUDE HOUSING. OF FROM
ITS PROVISIONS AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK THAT'S A A STEP
FORWARD. ORDINARILY WOULD NOT BE
MY AND.
INTENTION OR DESIRE TO EXPAND
THE SCOPE OF. A SECRET
PROVISIONS AT A TIME WHEN.
I THINK BECAUSE WE ALL SEE SOME
ISSUES SAID THAT NEED TO BE
RESOLVED WITH WITH SEQUINS ARE
MANY OF US TO.
HOWEVER IN THIS CASE.
BOB I THINK YOUR INTENTION IF I
UNDERSTAND IT PROPERLY IS SET TO
MAKE SURE THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. BOMBS ARE AWARE OF
SEQUEL WHICH A A AND THE
INTENTIONS REALLY PUT EVERYONE
ANA A SIMILAR FOOTING CUT SOME
COMMUNITIES. ARE. ARE ARE ARE
BETTER ABLE TO GET THE WORD OUT.
SURROUNDING PROJECTS.
AND SOMETIMES THE NATURE OF THE
PROJECT MAKES THAT TO MAKE THAT
DIFFICULT SO I THINK THAT.
OF THE INTENTION IS GOOD HERE
I'LL BE WATCHING TO SEE WHAT
AMENDMENTS ARE ARE MADE TO THE
BILL AND RESERVE. A A JUDGMENT
TO.
AT AFTER A FUTURE STAGE SHOULD
MAKE IT TO THE FLOOR RATHER
COMMITTEE THAT I SERVE ON.
THANK YOU DO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT THE INTENTION IS NOT TO
INCLUDE RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU.
MS VARIOUS IDEA.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK A WITH YOUR
OPPOSITION.
.
IN ADDITION TO.
MS EGGMAN AND MR BLOOM'S
CONCERNS ABOUT ADDING.
TO SEEK WERE.
.
WHEN.
MOST OF OUR CONVERSATIONS BEEN.
TRYING TO TAKE WITH THE OTHER
DIRECTION.
YEAH I I FULLY APPRECIATE THE
INTENT.
OF.
AND THE GOAL OF A OF YOUR BILL
THE MAIN GUY I THINK YOU TRY TO
GO TO THE HEART OF. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE MOVEMENT
WHICH IS THAT.
.
PLANNING AND LAND USE ISSUES.
DID NOT HAVE A DISCRIMINATORY.
IMPACT ON.
PROTECTED COMMUNITIES.
INSIGHTFUL APPRECIATE THAT I
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE THE. THE
THE ENHANCE NOTICE REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE I I RECOGNIZE THAT.
.
THAT.
IMMIGRANT LONG CAN KEEP
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR.
MADE.
.
HAVE A.
CHALLENGES THAT MAY NOT EXIST
AND.
.
OTHER COMMUNITIES.
IN IN TERMS OF RECEIVING
ADEQUATE NOTICE MY CONCERN US
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT A GUY I DO A.
SOUNDS LIKE I SHARE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THEM AS MELENDEZ.
.
THE.
DISCRIMINATION PROVISIONS A IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THAT SEQUEL IS
BEING EXTENDED TO SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDE.
.
EITHER INTENTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION ARE DESCRIPTIVE
DISCRIMINATORY EFFECT.
AND SO THIS IS OPENING.
.
A WHOLE NEW.
AREA OF POTENTIAL LITIGATION.
WITH SEQUEL.
I CAN CERTAINLY.
SEE HOW IT MAY BE.
EASIER TO PROVE INTENTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION OR OR OR OR TO BE
ABLE TO.
.
TO IDENTIFY.
EXAMPLES ARE EVIDENCE OF
INTENTIONAL DISCRIMINATION.
I'M PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DISCRIMINATORY EFFECT.
THEY THERE THERE IS SOME.
POINT SOME DISCUSSION.
.
THAT I READ ABOUT HOW
DISCRIMINATORY EFFECT.
IT WAS IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
MADE HOW HOW CAN YOU FORESEE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IN
THE FUTURE OF IN A FOR.
IF IF OF OF.
.
OF A RETAILER.
YOU KNOW.
MOVED INTO THE.
THAT THE LOCATION AND AND
EVERYTHING APPEARED TO BE.
FAIR AND NON DISCRIMINATORY ON
ITS FACE BUT THEN SUBSEQUENTLY
THE.
THE THE OCCUPANT OR THE LOW OR
THE THE.
.
THE THE THE OWNER OF THE
PROPERTY OR THE OPERATOR THE
PROPERTY IF THEY THEN PROCEED TO
DISCRIMINATE THERE. IS IS THAT
THE INTENT OF YOUR BILL TO.
TRY TO ADDRESS. THOSE TYPE OF
WOULD THAT WOULD THAT FALL UNDER
DISCRIMINATORY EFFECT.
I THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE THAT
WE DO NOT WANT INTENTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION TO BE PRACTICED.
BUT I ALSO HEAR THE OPPOSITION
AND. THEIR CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS AND OF THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT IS BEING PLACED ON THOSE
WHO MAKE THAT DETERMINATION SO
ABSOLUTELY HERE THAT.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE WORKING
REALLY HARD WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO FIGURE OUT THE LANGUAGE THAT
WE CAN USE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE CAN.
PUT INTO THIS BILL.
SO THAT IT CAN MOVE FORWARD.
BUT THAT IS A CONCERN AND I
ABSOLUTELY RECOGNIZE
THE THE PROOF.
THE THE THE FACTORS OF PROOF
THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH YEAH I
KNOW W HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
AND YOU HAVE PERSONALLY MADE THE
COMMITMENT TO ME.
TO.
WORK ON THIS.
I ALSO SIT ON ENVIRONMENT
SAFETY A COMMITTEE AND SO I WILL
BE LOOKING.
TO SEE YOUR PROGRESS
THANK YOU IT'LL BE GREAT
PROGRESS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
MISTRESS WAS LIKE CLOSE.
I UNDERSTAND MEMBERSIN CHAIR OF
THAT AS THE BILL IS IN PRINT.
IT IS A PERFECT.
BUT I.
DO GIVE YOU MY WORD THAT I WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE THE
OPPOSITION AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH. THE STATED HEART OF
THIS LEGISLATION WILL NOT
CREATING IN THE OWNERS
LITIGATION RISK.
WE DO HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES
AND THAT IS OUR PURPOSE.
AND.
AGAIN I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE.
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND WITH
STAKEHOLDERS
TO GET TO THAT POINT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND CHAIRS
RECOMMENDATION IS AN AYE.
MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HAS THERE BEEN IN MOTION AND A
SECOND. OKAY.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN BY MEMBER RAYOS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS REFER TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI ON REFUGEE
AYE ACOSTA. BLOOM.
BLOOM I'VE CHAO.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO STONE. STONE AYE.
FIVE TWO.
BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU.
ALRIGHT WE ARE DOWN TO OUR LAST
TWO BILLS I BELIEVE.
SO.
BY THE CALENDAR MISS EGGMAN AS
FIRST UP.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWO
THOUSAND SIX MS EGGMAN.
IT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
WOULD START OFF BY SAYING WE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK.
THIS IS AB TWO ZERO ZERO SIX
WHICH WILL PROVIDE RELIABLE AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION TO THE MANY
AGRICULTURE WORKERS AND OUR
STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S OF WHEN THE SIX
LARGEST ECONOMIES IN PART OF
THAT IS BECAUSE OF OUR RICH AND
DIVERSE AGRICULTURAL.
HISTORY AND AT WORK THAT WE DO.
ABNER THIS IS POSSILE WITHOUT.
OUR LABOURS WHO ARE OUT THERE
DOING THE WORK IN THE FIELDS UP
MANY OF THESE WORKERS AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE HAZING HOUSING CRISIS
HAVE TO TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES
OFTENTIMES THEY HAVE TO TAKE.
TRANSPORTATION HAT IS A. BUT
NOT THE CLEANEST.
.
THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD HAS
CREATIVE AMPLE PILOT PROJECT FOR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS WERE GONNA
STAND JOAQUIN VALLEY HOWEVER
THERE ARE OTHER DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OCCUR THAT EXIST
AROUND THE STATE.
ADD THE BAND PULLED SET OF
SERVICES THAT ARE. IN OPERATION
HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL TO
THIS BILL WILL CREATE A
STATEWIDE BEEN PUT PROGRAM
PROVIDE THESE WORKERS WITH THE
CLEANER MORE RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTION.
BUT IT WILL PROVIDE SUPPORT OUR
AGRICULTURE WORKERS BY PROVIDING
THEM WITH THE ESSENTIAL SERVICE
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY HELPING
REDUCE EMISSIONS BY CUTTING DOWN
THE NUMBER OF VEHICLES ON THE
ROADS. AND THERE A NUMBER OF
DIRTY VEHICLES ON THE ROADS
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I HOPE TO
CONTINUE THAT TRADITION IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
I HEAR THIS BILL DOES ENJOYED A
SUPPORT SUPPORT. RECOMMENDATION.
AT COULD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS A QUIBBLE SOME
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA VAMP
AUTHORITY. WE ARE JPA PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCY THAT PROVIDES
HAND HOW CULTURAL VAN POOLS TO.
FARMWORKERS ARE JUST UP QUICKLY
SAY LIKE LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN SAID FARMWORKERS LACK THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE.
THEMSELVES TRANSPORTATION TO
AND FROM WORK EVERY DAY AB TWO
THOUSAND SIX WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT FARMWORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE NOT JUST IN SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WOULD HAVE. ACCESS TO
RELIABLE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS RESPECTFULLY URGE.
AT YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IT'S IS PLEASE COME FORWARD. IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
IS AN OF US IN HERE AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ROOM TO
JUSTICE ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. BUT ALSO LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL BECOME BLOODY IS PART OF
THE BILL AND ALL SUMMER HIM HUNG
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTIVE ABOUT
THINKING.
BRANCH OVER THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE NEGER CULTURE NETWORKER
CAO CAN ASSIST AND SUPPORT.
Q.
FOR THE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE INSECT OF
MOTIONS WERE MADE IS OUR SECOND.
SECOND.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS EGGMAN WHICH LIKE CLOTHES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IVA THANK
YOU BROKE UP PLEASE.
I AM FOR AB TWO OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MATTEUCCI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN TRY EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA KILEY MON.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
STONE I.
ZERO.
BILL ITSELF.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT MISTER BLOOM
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THAT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
CLARIFY.
THE DEFINITION OF CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AREAS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA HABITATS MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE RESILIENT
IN THE FACE OF. ONGOING CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE STATE'S CURRENT CLIMATE
ADAPTION STRATEGY COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS THE SAFEGUARDING
PLAN IS A TRIENNIAL REPORT
PUBLISHED BY THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY.
THE PLANTS PURPOSE IS TO
IDENTIFY STATE AND REGIONAL
CLIMATE CHANGE VULNERABILITIES
AND POTENTIAL STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS THESE VULNERABILITIES.
AUTHORED BY THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GORDON AND TWENTY FIFTEEN THIS
REPORT IS THE STATE'S A ROADMAP
FOR EVERYTHING STATE AGENCIES
ARE DOING AND WILL DO.
PROTECT COMMUNITIES
INFRASTRUCTURE SERVICES IN THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS.
AFTER SEVERAL YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION IT'S BECOME CLEAR
THAT THE PLAN IS MISSING A
CRITICAL ELEMENT RELATED TO
HABITAT. THAT CONSERVATIVE
CRITICAL PROTECTION OR AS WE
LIKE TO CALL THEM SOURCE WATERS
AND STRONGHOLDS
TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO BE
RESILIENT. IN THE FACE OF
UNAVOIDABLE IMPACTS RECLINE.
AND TO THAT END I'VE INTRODUCED
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT TO
BUILD OFF TO OFF OF OF MR
GORDON'S WORK AND TO ADD TO THE
EXISTING LANGUAGE.
THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT AREAS
MOST IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM RESILIENCE ARE ADEQUATELY
ANALYZED AND CONSIDERED FOR LONG
TERM IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THESE INCLUDE SPRING FED SOURCE
WATERSHEDS
SALMON AND STEEL HEAD
STRONGHOLDS MOUNTAIN MEADOWS AND
ESTUARIES.
THIS BILL HIGHLIGHTS IMPORTANT
ECOSYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
FROM PRODUCTIVE ESTUARIES THAT'S
A QUESTION.
A QUESTOR CARBON TO HIGH SIERRA
ALL CONDUCT VOLCANIC AQUIFER
SYSTEMS THAT PRODUCE SICK
THE PERCENT OF THE VOLUME OF
SHASTA RESERVOIR. TO MOUNTAIN
MEADOWS THAT STORE AND RELEASE
WATER DURING THE RIGHT TIMES OF
THE YEAR IN THE FACE.
DWINDLING SNOWPACK
AND WITHIN A HALF PET SAMUEL
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
TROUT. AND DR CARSON JEFFRIES
WITH THE UC DAVIS CENTER FOR
WATERSHED SCIENCES
WHO OF THE BILL PICKED
PROTECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CARSON JEFFRIES AND I'M ABOUT
DIRECTOR AND CO DIRECTOR FOR THE
UC DAVIS AND OF WATERSHED
SCIENCES.
DO YOU SEE DAVIS HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN WATER SCIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I PERSONALLY HAVE
SPENT THE LAST TWELVE YEARS
WORKING ON SPRING FED SYSTEMS IN
THE NORTH STATE.
SOURCE WATERS IN THE SHASTA
REGION SUPPLY AN ESTIMATED FORTY
PERCENT OF THE STATE'S
HYDROELECTRIC POWER AND
CONTRIBUTE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
BILLION GALLONS OF WATER NOT
SHASTA WHICH ULTIMATELY IS USED
FOR AGRICULTURE AND HUMAN WATER
USE AS WELL AS ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES.
THE SPRING PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
IMPORTANT SYSTEM OF THE WATER
QUESTION FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
DURING THE DROWNED TWENTY
FIFTEEN D. SYSTEM STILL MAINTAIN
WATER THAT WAS ULTIMATELY PUT
UNDER SHASTA AND USED FOR MANY
PURPOSES.
AS RESEARCH ON BIODIVERSITY AND
HABITAT INVOLVED IT'S BECOME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT CERTAIN
WATERSHEDS WILL NEED TO BE. OUR
BEST CHANCE AND MAINTAINING
RESILIENCE AS WE FACE
UNAVOIDABLE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE INCLUDING CHANGING
HYDROLOGICAL PATTERNS DROUGHT
AND CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT CURRENTLY
PLAN TO ADEQUATELY PROTECT ITS
MOST IMPORTANT WATERSHEDS FROM
IMPACTS OF A CHANGING CLIMATE.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THEM
BETTER ACKNOWLEDGED THEIR VALUE
TO PEOPLE AGRICULTURE WILDLIFE.
AND PREPARE FOR TIMES AHEAD WHEN
THEY MAY BE THE LAST CHANCE TO
PROVIDE CONSISTENT CLEAN AND
COLD WATER FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY AND I ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY THANK YOU.
IF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PATRICK SAMUEL A BAY AREA
PROGRAM MANAGER CALIFORNIA
TROUT.
I'M HERE TODAY TO UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT AND THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH IN THESE
AREAS THAT WILL BE BELIEVE WILL
BE CALIFORNIA'S BEST CHANCE FOR
ONGOING RESILIENCE IN THE FACE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE EXISTING SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA PLANNED PUSHES THE
CLIMATE ADAPTATION CONVERSATION
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE ADDITIONS
HIGHLY IMPORTANT PRIORITIES THAT
DESERVE ANALYSIS AND DISCUSSION.
THE STATE'S CLIMATE ADAPTATION
STRATEGY IDENTIFIES
VULNERABILITIES THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED IN A CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICY.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD ASK A NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
THESE FOUR RESILIENCE AREAS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. ARE SENATE
STILL HAD STRONGHOLDS OR SOURCE
WATERSHEDS MOUNTAIN MEADOWS AND
ESTUARIES.
WELL SOME IMPORTANT CLIMATE
IMPACTS MAY BE UNAVOIDABLE
CALIFORNIA CAN WORK TOWARDS
BUILDING A MORE EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY SPECIFICALLY BY
INCLUDING THESE KEY WATER
ECOSYSTEMS OF THE STATE.
BY MAINTAINING RESILIENCE AND
MITIGATING THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IN CERTAIN AREAS.
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN ECOLOGICAL FUNCTION AND
ABUNDANT CLEAN WATER SOURCES
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS DEPEND
UPON NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON PAUL MAY SO
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST I'M
THRILLED TO SEE MISTER BLOOM
AGAIN WORKING ON A WATERSHED ON
THE CLIMATE SORT OF BILL WE HAD
THEM COULD PUT GOOD FORTUNATE IN
A COUPLE YEARS AGO. AND I THINK
IS IMPORTANT HERE IS RECOGNIZING
THAT NOT EVERY ACRE OF
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BE
EQUALLY RELEVANT TO MAINTAINING
SOME OF THESE REALLY IMPORTANT
VALUES LIKE CALLED CLEAN WATER.
SALMON AND STEELHEAD IN
IDENTIFYING THOSE AREAS THAT DO
PLAY THAT DISPROPORTIONATE ROLE
SLICK THOSE SPRING FED RIVERS UP
IN THE NORTH NORTH STATE. TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT MAKING SURE WE
PRIORITIZE THOSE SORTS OF
CONSERVATION RESTORATION
INVESTMENTS OF THE WE HAVE WATER
TO RELY ON THIRTY YEARS FROM
NOW.
SO VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA AND MO ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA SUPPORT.
YOU FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
I'M SORRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON NOEL CREAMERS THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION BUT I DID WANT
TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS SOME CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE BILL AND.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS TO TRY TO. FIGURE OUT
THOSE WILL CONTINUE BUT.
OUR CONCERN IS.
UP WITH THE VERY SPECIFIC
DEFINITIONS INCLUDED IN THE BILL
THAT. MOVING FORWARD.
THIS COULD CREATE ADDITIONAL
SEQUEL REQUIREMENTS AND
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
FOLKS WITHIN THOSE SOURCE
WATERSHED SO WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT THAT WOULD
HAVE ON WATER AVAILABILITY TO
FARMERS IN THAT AREA. WERE ALSO
CONCERNED I'M GENERALLY ABOUT
WATER AVAILABILITY STATEWIDE AND
IF THERE ARE RESTRICTIONS PLACED
ON THOSE SOURCE WATERSHEDS TO
PROTECT THEM.
WHERE WE GONNA GET OUR WATER I'M
AS WE TALKED ABOUT THAT?
SUPPLYING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF WATER STATEWIDE SO I'M WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION IS TO ENSURE THAT.
THE EFFORTS TO AND THINK ABOUT
HOW DO WE MANAGE THESE AREAS
DON'T THEN HAVE CONSEQUENCES ON
ON.
THOSE USING THOSE RESOURCES
TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY OF FOR THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
QUESTIONS.
MUCH HAS BEEN MADE. THAT WHAT'S
BEEN MADE AND SECONDED ALREADY.
AND HE.
OTHER QUESTIONS NONE MISTER
CLUMPS LIKE CLOSE. AT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE DISCUSSIONS
WITH OF THOSE WHO HAVE AN
INTEREST IN REFINING THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT AT SHARES RECOMMENDATION
I WITH AMENDMENTS WHICH HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTED BROKAW PUTS.
I MADE AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
IN REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS WERE OUT
SEARCHING AYE THROUGHOUT THE GI
ACOSTA BLOOM FIVE BLOOM AYE CHAU
CHAU I EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO.
LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES
NO STONE.
STONE I.
TO FILL IS OUT.
ALRIGHT THAT'S A.
INCLUDE WELL WE.
FOLKS I WANT TO ADD ON.
OKAY SO.
WE ARE LEFT IN THE CALL.
FIRST ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE.
MISTER YOU GARCIA.
ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE YOU GARCIA TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FOR DEATH
ZERO. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE LOAN.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES NO STONE.
STONE I.
IT'S ONE.
YEAH.
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN BY AGUIAR CURRY DO PASS
AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FOR TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ABSENT MEMBERS
ACOSTA CHAU CHAU AYE LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
AYE STONE.
STONE I.
EIGHT ZERO BILLS OUT.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN RAILS TO PASS REFERRED TO.
INTERNAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIAL COMMITTEE OF CURRENT
VOTE FIVE TO TWO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I HAVE TO MEMBERS ACOSTA.
CHAU CHAU AYE LIMON.
STU ELLIS OUT.
AND ITEM TEN AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN FRIEDMAN DO PASS AS
AMENDED REFER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. CURRENT
VOTE THREE TO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE ABSENT MEMBERS
ACOSTA CHAU. CHAU AYE LIMON.
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S NOT VOTING STONE.
STONE I.
ZERO.
THE BILL IS NOW.
RIGHT AND.
SO WE WILL OPEN IT UPFOR FOLKS
WHO WANT TO ADD ON TO ANY OF THE
VOTES.
TELL ME IN THE DO IT ON THE
MONEY OR THE YEAH WE JUST DID IT
ON THE MICA.
CORD CAN FIFTEEN.
WHAT?
JUST ONE RECORD.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY BILLS
AUTUMN.
YEAH I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
THANK GOODNESS I AM JUST GOING
TO CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOT NECESSARILY A BILL. THAT
SMOKING AND ALL THAT.
ON ITEM ONE A. B. NINETEEN NO
ONE.
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE STONE.
STONE NO.
EIGHT ONE.
ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE EDUARDO GARCIA.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA.
NO.
ACOSTA NO.
LIMON.
SEVEN ONE NO FROM SORRY.
SEVEN TWO.
I DON'T FOR A BI TWO OH SIX
EGGMAN. ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NINE ZERO.
I DON'T FIVE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN IRWIN. ABSENT
MEMBERS CHILD.
CHAU AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY.
STONE AYE TEN ZERO.
FIVE AND SIX AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY SEVEN RAYOS ABSENT MEMBERS
ACOSTA.
NO ACOSTA NO. LIMON.
THREE.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN AGUIAR CURRY ABSENT
MEMBERS ACOSTA.
ACOSTA I LIMON.
NINE ZERO.
I DID MAY AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT BLOOM. ABSENT MEMBERS
ACOSTA NO ACOSTA NO LIMON.
SIX THREE.
I DON'T CHEN AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN FRIEDMAN.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA THAT
VOTING ACOSTA NOT VOTING.
LIMON.
ZERO.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTY THIRTY
SIX COOLEY ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STONE.
STONE AYE TEN ZERO.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE BERMAN. ABSENT
MEMBERS LIMON.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
STONE I NINE ZERO.
I DON'T FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY GRAYSON. ABSENT MEMBERS
EGGMAN.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN DOES NOT VOTING STONE.
STONE I.
EIGHT ZERO.
GOING ABOUT LIGHTNING
ACROSS
I.
DON'T. HAVE IGN OFFICE CAUSE
AGREES.
YEAH
REOPEN THE ROLE FOR TO ADD ON
VOTES.
ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE EDUARDO GHOST GARCIA ABSENT
MEMBERS AMONG.
I.
LIMON I.
EIGHT TO.
I AM FOR AB TWENTY ALL SIX
EGGMAN.
ABSENT MEMBERS LIMON AYE LEMOND
AYE.
TEN ZERO.
I DON'T SIX AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN ABSENT MEMBERS LIMON AYE
LIMON I. SEVEN THREE.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
DI LIMON AYE TENDS ZERO.
ITEM EIGHT TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT BLOOM. ABSENT MEMBERS
MOMENT BY LIMON I SEVEN THREE.
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
ABSENT MEMBERS AMONG HIGH.
LIMON I.
SEVEN ZERO.
ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE BERMAN ABSENT
MEMBERS LIMON AYE AYE LIMON AYE
TENDS ZERO.
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HOLDING
THAT OPENED THINK YOU.
ALRIGHT THIS MEETING ADJOURNED